Hi, this is Larry David. I've been asked to say that I'm going to be on the show later. So I'm complying with that request. Yeah, welcome to what is this? I don't even know what I'm on here. What is this? Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Hi everybody, Jason, I love that you're still here in town. I didn't know you were gonna be here.
嗨，我是拉里·大卫。我被要求说我待会儿会参加这个节目。所以我照办了。好吧，欢迎来到……这是什么？我都不知道我上的是什么节目。这是什么？Lattice。Smart。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。大家好，杰森，很高兴你还在城里。我不知道你要来。
I know, look at you. I am working remotely this week, yes, from Los Angeles. Wonderful. Where it's got New York weather today. It's nice and rainy. I love it. That's some nice rain. Warring rain.
我知道，看看你。我这周远程办公，是的，从洛杉矶。太棒了。那儿今天的天气跟纽约一样。又好又下雨。我喜欢。这雨下得真舒服。扰人的雨。
Do you guys like weather? Or do you love the Southern California 75 degrees? Hey man, I'm not single, so. I don't know where this is going. Hey guys, what's your favorite season? Hey, do you like weather? Come over here real quick. Can I talk to you for a second?
你们喜欢天气吗？还是说你们更喜欢南加州75华氏度（约24摄氏度）的天气？嘿，伙计，我又不是单身，所以……我不知道这话题要扯到哪儿去了。嘿，伙计们，你们最喜欢哪个季节？嘿，你们喜欢天气吗？过来一下。能跟你说句话吗？
Yeah, it's nice. I prefer it. Well, it's very Chicago-y. Yeah, but you would like 75 and breezy 365 days of the year? No. Yeah, I don't like the heat, so that's an issue. I don't mind it. But you wouldn't mind some snow and some rain, would you?
对，挺好的。我更喜欢这样。嗯，很有芝加哥的感觉。对，但你难道不想一年365天都有24度还带微风吗？不想。对，我其实不太喜欢热，所以这是个问题。我不介意热。但你不会介意下点雪和雨吧，对吧？
That's what I'm saying. I actually enjoy this. I think I've told you this before. I live in such a snow, I grew up in such a snow I grew up in such a snow snowy point Well, not really that snowy but but cold to the extent that this morning dropping the kids of the bus It was raining and stuff and I saw this one that great Sean how he just takes him just to the bus stop You can't take them all the way to school like some of us. I don't live in the valley. So yeah so anyway, I
这就是我要说的。我其实挺享受这样的。我想我以前跟你说过。我住在一个下雪，我是在一个下雪，我是在一个下雪雪很多的地方长大——好吧，其实也没有那么多雪——但是冷到什么程度呢，今天早上送孩子们去坐校车的时候，在下雨什么的，然后我看到有个家伙，真棒，肖恩，他怎么就把他们送到公交车站就算了。你不能像我们有些人一样，把他们一直送到学校。我不住在山谷里。所以，总之，我
See see I see a road that's going up off Beverly Glen, like really steep little side road, and I had this in my old house, like, boy man, it's going to be tough when it gets icy. It doesn't get icy. No. Oh, so your brain just immediately, huh. My old house, when I was going to buy it, I thought, like, fuck, how am I going to get up this thing when it ices?
看到，看到一条从贝弗利格伦向上延伸的道路，那是一条非常陡峭的小侧路，我以前的房子也有这种情况，就像，天哪，结冰的时候肯定很难走。那里不会结冰。不会。哦，所以你的大脑立刻就开始转了，是吧。我以前的房子，当时打算买的时候，我在想，靠，结冰的时候我怎么开得上去啊？
And then like, oh, it doesn't get ices. Never ices. Never ices. Oh, my God, that's incredible. I know. By the way, sorry, go ahead, Sean, you were gonna say something, but... No, you go. You go. Well, I was just gonna say, because I realized as I'm talking,
然后心想，哦，这里不会结冰。从来不结冰。从来不结冰。噢天哪，这太神奇了。我知道。顺便说一句，对不起，你继续，肖恩，你刚才想说什么来着，但是……不，你请。你请。嗯，我只是想说，因为我在说话的时候突然意识到，
I did one of those, another mistake, I got one of those emails and it had the thing there, and it had like reviews buried in the email. I open it up and then it has like a couple about the podcast. One of them was one star and it said, does Will only get one hour to speak a week because he just wouldn't shut up. And I'm like, I'm giving this guy satisfaction,
我又犯了个错，我收到了其中一封邮件，里面有那个东西，邮件里还夹着一些评论。我打开一看，发现有几条是关于播客的。其中一条给了一星，上面写着：“威尔一周就只有一小时说话时间吗，因为他根本闭不上嘴。”然后我想，我这是在满足这家伙的愿望，
but at the same time I'm thinking like, it's free, right? He didn't pay anything for it. Could turn it off. But he's implying that he would gladly pay a little bit to shut you up a lot. I guess so, and or it made him so mad this thing he's implying that he would gladly pay a little bit to shut you up a lot I guess so and or it made him so mad this thing He's getting for free that he went online and typed out a message gave the podcast one star time Oh, Willie don't read that you want to read those well. I do it for you guys. I'm out here
但同时我又在想，这节目是免费的对吧？他又没花一分钱。大不了关掉呗。但他话里暗示，他其实很乐意花点小钱好让你彻底闭嘴。我想是的，或者这节目是他白嫖的，却让他气得不行，以至于他跑到网上敲下一段话，给播客打了一星。哦，威利，别看那种东西。你想看那些吗？嗯，我是为了你们才看的。我在这儿
You want me on that wall? You know you need this but it's a specific subset of our listeners that actually take the time to write something, something not so nice. Yeah. And like, is it a full representation of our audience? I don't know. I don't know.
你想让我上那面墙吗？你知道你需要这个，但实际上只有我们听众中的一小部分人，才会花时间去写点东西，写点不太好听的东西。对。而且，这能完全代表我们的受众吗？我不知道。我不知道。
It was very hostile towards me. We take it under advisement though. Yeah, we take it under advisement. So I'm gonna shut up. I wanted to tell you. Well don't do that, but. No, don't do that. I wanted to tell you that but don't do that I wanted to tell you what he's saying is he he likes you at an 80 love you at a five
他对我的敌意太大了。不过我们会把意见记下来的。对，我们会把意见记下来的。所以我这就闭嘴。我本来想告诉你——嗯，别这样，但是。不，别这样。我本来想告诉你这个的——但他这么说其实是想表达，他对你的喜欢程度是80分，爱你只有5分。
No, no, no, he wants me at a zero. I Love that you're just like then just don't listen. I get it. I Was chatting with will very briefly this morning You guys talk before we talk? Not usually. Not usually. You guys running over bits? Yeah. Okay, so listen, so you set me up with this. And I texted, and Jay I texted you a lot last night.
不，不，不，他希望我的好感度是零。我就喜欢你这种“那你就别听啊”的态度。我懂。我今天早上跟威尔简单聊过一会儿。你们在我们录制前聊过？通常没有。通常没有。你们俩在对暗号吗？对。好吧，听着，所以你给我挖了个坑。然后我发短信了，杰—我昨晚给你发了好多短信。
I was like, I think I reached my text limit with Jason. What, last night? Last night or two nights ago. Wait, let me look here. I don't see any texts from you. Yeah, I was like. I don't see any texts from you. Oh wait, here it is. No, we were texting back and forth.
我还以为我给杰森发短信发到上限了呢。什么，昨晚？昨晚还是前天晚上。等等，让我看看。我没看到你发的信息。对，我当时就……我没看到你发的信息。哦等等，在这儿呢。不，我们一直在发短信。
Oh, about Scotty? Yeah, about Scotty, yeah. That wasn't a lot. Yeah. Did you hear about Scotty, Sean? No, what happened? Sorry. No.
哦，关于斯科蒂的？对，关于斯科蒂的，对。那也没多少。对。你听说斯科蒂的事了吗，肖恩？没有，发生什么事了？抱歉。没有。
Oh, yeah, it's not working out. Scotty's out. Scotty's out. Almost 18 years. Yeah. Yeah, so Sean is trying to figure out what to do with the weekend to take full advantage of it. Let's talk about the weather, Jason.
哦，对，干不下去了。斯科蒂被炒了。斯科蒂被炒了。将近18年呢。对。对，所以肖恩正在琢磨周末该怎么过，才能彻底好好享受一下。我们来聊聊天气吧，杰森。
He's tech avail LA. Yeah, he's just ordered a box of glow sticks from Amazon for the weekend. No, I wanted to tell you, so I was eating breakfast, I walked past the bathroom and this is the craziest thing. Scotty loves peanut butter. Why is my sound going out? Oh, can you hear?
他在科技界挺吃香的，在洛杉矶。对，他刚在亚马逊上订了一箱荧光棒准备周末用。不，我想告诉你的是，我当时正在吃早饭，路过浴室，这事儿太疯狂了。斯科蒂特别喜欢花生酱。我的声音怎么断了？哦，你听得见吗？
Oh, there we go, okay, go ahead. Hang on one second. Sorry, let me remind you where you were. So Scotty loves peanut butter, go ahead. Right. Wait, by the way. No, this is really interesting. Do you think that this would fit
哦，行了，好，你接着说。等一下。抱歉，我提醒一下你刚才说到哪了。所以斯科蒂喜欢花生酱，你继续。对。等等，顺便说一句。不，这真的很有趣。你觉得这能算进
into the breaking news category? Absolutely. Did you guys find each other on the PB&J freak site? Well, that's fun because I love jelly. Where's your address? That's... Why is that? It's not that even that good.
突发新闻类别吗？当然。你们是在花生酱果酱怪胎网站上认识彼此的吗？好吧，这挺有意思的，因为我喜欢果酱。你家地址在哪？那是……为什么会这样？甚至都没那么好。
Could you imagine? PB&J like- Love to spread a little of you on me. Like a food dating site. We could make, the two of us together would make a great meal. By the way, it's not supposed to be a dating site. It's supposed to be just- Just a culinary site.
你能想象吗？花生酱果酱就像——喜欢把你的点滴涂抹在我身上。就像一个食品约会网站。我们可以，我们俩在一起绝对能凑成一顿大餐。顺便说一句，这本来就不是什么约会网站。它应该只是——只是一个美食网站。
A peanut butter appreciation site turned into a dating site. They got married at the GIF headquarters. The culinary site. The peanut butter appreciation site turned into a taste. They got married at the JIF headquarters. Okay, so here we go. Here we go. Do you like JIF? This is funny, this is funny actually. Do you like JIF?
一个花生酱鉴赏网站结果变成了约会网站。他们甚至在吉夫（JIF）总部结了婚。这个美食网站。这个花生酱鉴赏网站变成了一个品味网站。他们甚至在JIF总部结了婚。好吧，那我们继续。我们继续。你喜欢JIF吗？这挺逗的，其实挺逗的。你喜欢JIF吗？
Scott, oh Sean? I'm in a JIF. I do like that. Scott, he loves peanut butter. I would love to see a taste test between JIF and Skippy. Sorry, go ahead. Let's do it. When his blood sugar is low, okay, because he's got diabetes, he'll go in the pantry
斯科—哦，肖恩？我挺喜欢JIF的。我确实挺喜欢。斯科蒂，他特别喜欢花生酱。我很想看JIF和斯基皮（Skippy）的花生酱盲测。抱歉，你继续。搞起。当他血糖低的时候，好吧，因为他有糖尿病，他就会去储藏室
and scoop out a spoonful of peanut butter. And every time any one of us goes to get peanut butter, Ricky, the dog, can smell it and he comes over there and sits there and he drools like crazy and there's like a puddle of his dog spit. So it's cute and disgusting all at the same time. And it's created a bad habit because we always cave in and give him some peanut butter.
挖一勺花生酱吃。而且每次我们中间有谁去拿花生酱时，那只叫里奇的狗都能闻到味儿，它就会跑过来坐在那儿，口水直流三千尺，地上会有一滩它的狗口水。所以这事儿看起来既可爱又恶心。而且这也养成了个坏习惯，因为我们总是经不住哀求，会分给他一点花生酱。
So now we have to find a way to sneak the peanut butter when the dog is sleeping in another room. So this morning I walk by the bathroom near the kitchen and I'm like, are you in there? And he said, yeah, I'm eating peanut butter. I said, in the bathroom? He said, yeah, it's the only way to avoid the dog. Boy.
所以现在我们不得不动脑筋，趁狗狗在另一个房间睡觉时偷偷去拿花生酱。所以今天早上我路过厨房附近的浴室时，我就问：“你在里面吗？”他说：“对，我在吃花生酱。”我说：“在浴室里？”他说：“对，只有这样才能躲开那只狗。”天哪。
I remember when, yeah. What? You know, it's just, when I was kid, that was the only place to get privacy and I would do different things in the bathroom than sneak peanut butter. He really truly brought the jar of peanut butter. But you know what, both you and Scotty have the same,
我记得以前，对。什么？你知道的，就，我小时候那是唯一能独处的地方，我在浴室里干的事可比偷吃花生酱多多了。他居然真的把一整罐花生酱给带进去了。但你知道吗，你和斯科蒂都有个共同点，
you end up with the same result. Right, you both finish. I thought that was odd and funny. Guys. It was, it's definitely. Here's somebody who's funny but not odd. Huh, what about that? Not great, but go ahead. He's a very talented pal of mine.
你们最后的结果都一样。没错，你们都完事了。我觉得这事儿又古怪又好笑。伙计们。这确实，绝对是。这里有个人很好笑但一点也不古怪。哈，这人怎么样？虽然算不上绝佳，但你接着说。他是一个非常出色的老朋友。
He's had more success than the three of us combined. Like many comedians, he's got standup and Saturday Night Live on his resume. But before making his mark on the comedy zeitgeist of the last half century, he got his bachelor's degree in history, worked as a private chauffeur with the uniform and everything, and was selling bras at wholesale.
他的成功比我们三个加起来还要多。跟许多喜剧演员一样，他的履历上有单口喜剧和《周六夜现场》。但在他于过去半个世纪的喜剧文化中留下印记之前，他拿过历史学学士学位，当过穿着制服一应俱全的私人司机，还做过胸罩批发。
Things took a major turn for him in 1988 when he started to work on a little pilot called The Seinfeld Chronicles. It's my very hilarious friend, Larry David. Larry David? Larry! Oh, look at him, oh, look at him. He's already bored, he's already bored.
1988年，他的人生迎来了重大转折，当时他开始参与一部名为《宋飞传》（The Seinfeld Chronicles）的小试播集。他就是我非常搞笑的朋友，拉里·大卫。拉里·大卫？拉里！哦，看他那表情，哦，看他那表情。他已经开始无聊了，他已经无聊了。
How disgusting. Already, how about 15 minutes? I apologize, it definitely comes out of your time, so that's a good thing. You're gonna be with us for another 45 minutes. But here's the sad part. By the way, the dog thing, I love when the dogs are out of the house
多让人扫兴啊。这就开始了，15分钟怎么样？我很抱歉，这绝对是占用了你的时间，所以这是件好事。你还要跟我们再待45分钟。但悲伤的部分来了。顺便说一句，关于那只狗的事，我太喜欢狗不在家的时候了，
so I can have a meal. That's what I'm saying. And relax. That's what I'm saying. You can't eat with them. That's what I'm saying. That's your fault probably, or Ashley's, right? You fed them, and now they don't forget that.
这样我才能吃顿饭。这就是我要说的。然后好好放松。这就是我要说的。你根本没法跟它们一起吃。这就是我要说的。这大概是你的错，或者阿什莉的错，对吧？你们喂过它们，现在它们忘不了这事儿了。
No, she started feeding them from the table. It's all her fault. I gave her a dirty look, but she did it, and now. Once you make her eat outside with the dogs, I'll teach her, and she'll never do it again. I'm telling you, I take snacks into my bathroom. I do. Right, because of the dogs?
不，是她开始从餐桌上喂它们的。全都是她的怪。我狠狠地瞪了她一眼，但她还是这么做了，然后。等你让她去外面跟狗一起吃，我调教她一下，她就再也不敢了。跟你说，我都会把零食带进浴室。我真的会。对，因为那些狗？
Yeah, because of the dogs. That's what I'm saying, so somebody, yeah, you can relate. Larry, I'm so glad you're finally here. Did we just finally made your deal? It took so long. I know. What do you mean? God, your business affairs was just, I guess, was your agent just beating us up?
对，因为那些狗。这就是我要说的，所以有人，对，你能感同身受。拉里，我太高兴你终于来了。我们总算敲定你的合约了？花了这么长时间。我知道。什么意思？天哪，你们的商务事务部简直——我猜，难道是你的经纪人在狠狠压榨我们？
What are you involved in business affairs? We're not, we're kidding. This is all for you. Oh, you were joking. He was joking. By the way, you know, I... I get that a lot. A lot of surprise.
你什么时候关心起商务事务了？我们没关心，开玩笑的。这都是为了你。哦，你在开玩笑。他是在开玩笑。顺便说一句，你知道，我……这种事我见多了。经常大吃一惊。
Oh, sorry, it was humor? I really sneak up on folks. Check your six. What the fuck? That's so good. Can we talk about Sean's appearance on Curb this year? Wow, it was gonna get there. I haven't seen it yet. Has it been on?
哦，抱歉，这是幽默？我真的很擅长给人来个出其不意。当心背后。卧槽？这也太棒了。我们能聊聊肖恩今年在《抑制热情》（Curb）里的客串吗？哇，终于扯到这上面了。我还没看过呢。已经播了吗？
If we have to. All right, so speaking of making deals, you made a Sean Hayes deal and got him on the show. Yeah. And? And. He's a long time coming. Do you have notes?
如果我们非得聊的话。好吧，那说到谈合同，你跟肖恩·海耶斯签了合同，让他上了这档节目。对。然后呢？然后。这可是酝酿已久的事。你有什么评价吗？
Be fucking real. At the time of my life. Be honest. I'm gonna be as honest as I can. Yeah. He was fantastic. I don't know about him. I'll bet he was just fine. Listen, he was, no, fantastic. I don't know about him. I bet he was just fine.
说句掏心窝子的话。老实说。我会尽量实话实说的。好吧。他表现得棒极了。我对他可说不好。我敢打赌他表现得刚刚好。听着，他，不，太棒了。我对他可说不好。我敢打赌他表现得刚刚好。
No, fantastic. He played a lawyer and you believe this guy was a lawyer. And he had to do a scene where he wakes up in the morning. It was like Gene Hackman from The French Connection. Oh boy. The acting display of him getting up in the morning. Sure. The whole deal.
不，简直太棒了。他演了一个律师，你真的会相信这家伙就是个律师。他得演一场早上刚醒来的戏。那感觉就像《法国贩毒网》（The French Connection）里的吉恩·哈克曼（Gene Hackman）。天哪。他刚起床时的那个演技大爆发。妥妥的。整套动作下来。
I was like, my mouth dropped. I was in love. I added wiping my eyes. Wiping your eyes. It was real Jean-Acte. Did you start with a... Yeah, a little bit. Which, Sean has the worst sleep hygiene I imagine of the four of us here. So that must have, you had to dig deep. Did you study people's sleep? How did you do it, Sean has the worst sleep hygiene I imagine of the four of us here, so that must have,
当时我都惊呆了。我简直爱死他了。我还加上了揉眼睛的动作。揉眼睛。那真有吉恩·哈克曼的风范。你是不是从一个……对，稍微来了一点。不过，我猜肖恩在我们这四个人里睡眠质量是最差的。所以那次你肯定，你必须得深入挖掘。你有研究过人们睡觉吗？你是怎么做到的，肖恩在我们这四个人里睡眠质量是最差的，所以那次你肯定，
you had to dig deep. Did you study people sleeping? How'd you do it, Sean? Cause you have no idea. I watched hours of tape. Yeah, okay. Of just people sleeping. Of people that weren't wearing the mask.
你必须得深入挖掘。你有研究过人们睡觉吗？你是怎么做到的，肖恩？因为你根本不知道。我看了好几个小时的录像。对，好吧。就只是人们睡觉的录像。没戴眼罩的人的录像。
Laird, but that was one of the, I don't know, Curb has been one of my favorite shows forever and ever and I loved being on it. I was honored to be asked. I was honored to do it with you, and on the last season nonetheless. Yeah. Will, did you ever get on that show?
拉里，但那是，我不知道，《抑制热情》一直是我最喜欢的节目之一，我太喜欢参与其中了。我很荣幸能被邀请。我很荣幸能跟你一起合作，而且还是在最后一季。对。威利，你以前上过那个节目吗？
No, I was never asked. Yeah, me neither. Oh boy. Not once. Larry said to me, Larry, do you remember this? Like about a year ago I ran into you, and Larry said, hey. Oh hey, you should be on the show.
没有，从来没人邀请过我。对，我也是。天哪。一次都没有。拉里曾对我说过，拉里，你还记得这事吗？大概一年前我碰见你的时候，拉里说，嘿。哦，嘿，你应该上这个节目。
He said, how come you, he did. And he goes, how come you, he goes, how come you were never on Curb? I said, first of all I said what, because I think I'm too tall. And then I said, it's your show, you never asked me. That's why, it's the primary reason. It is true, just about everybody in Hollywood
他说，你怎么，他真的这么说了。然后他说，你怎么，他说，你怎么从来没上过《抑制热情》？我说，首先我说什么来着，因为我觉得我太高了。然后我说，这是你的节目，你从来没邀请过我。这就是原因，这是最主要的原因。确实如此，好莱坞几乎所有人
has either been on that show or Law & Order. And not us, although Willie, you've done a Law & Order. But I would say this, now I take pride in the fact that I wasn't, now it makes it more, I'm in a more exclusive club. I'm like the Marty Scorsese of never winning the best Oscar for directing with regards to. Of course, Susan Lucci.
要么上过那个节目，要么上过《法律与秩序》（Law & Order）。除了我们，不过威利，你倒是演过《法律与秩序》。但我想说的是，我现在反而为自己没上过而感到骄傲，这让我显得更与众不同了，我加入了一个更小众的俱乐部。关于这一点，我就像是从未获得过奥斯卡最佳导演奖的马丁·斯科塞斯（Marty Scorsese）。当然还有苏珊·鲁奇（Susan Lucci）。
Well, it does sound like, I will say, it does sound like a really, from what I've heard from my friends that have been on the show, that it's like one of the greatest experiences. It's like up there with Sirenite Live. It's just an incredible group and you're improvising. I think it's the improvising. Actors really love to improvise. But I'll bet you've had some that have been like, forget it, I will sink in that atmosphere,
嗯，听起来——我得说，从那些上过节目的朋友那里听来的情况来看，这听起来确实是一次非常棒的体验。这感觉就像《周六夜现场》一样顶级。这是一群不可思议的人，而且你们是在即兴表演。我觉得关键就在于即兴表演。演员们真的很喜欢即兴发挥。但我敢说，肯定有些人会觉得，算了吧，在这种氛围里我根本吃不消，
do not, I'm not coming on. Yes, not many, but there have been a few who really couldn't do it. Had a tough time. What do you do about those who say, oh yeah, great, no, I love improvising, and they come on and they're just horrendous. What do you, how do you, who has a conversation with them?
打死我也不去。对，虽然不多，但确实有那么几个真的应付不来。觉得很难。对于那些嘴上说“哦，太棒了，不，我超爱即兴表演”，结果来了之后表现得一塌糊涂的人，你们会怎么处理？你们会怎么做，谁去跟他们谈话？
You or the director? What, you mean somebody who we've asked to do it? To do it, and they clearly are way over their skis with improvisation, do you do a, okay guys, let's take a quick five, can I talk to you for a second? It's only happened a couple of times in the show where people were trying to be funny.
是你还是导演？什么，你是说我们请来的人？让他们来演，但他们在即兴表演方面明显力不从心，你会不会说：“好吧，各位，我们休息五分钟，我能跟你谈一下吗？”在节目中这种情况只发生过几次，当时大家都在试图搞笑。
Right, right. Right. And that's like the worst thing you could ever do. And that's a hard note to give what what does that sound like? Do you do you pull the outside don't I here's the note? Yeah, don't try to be funny. That's shit. Wow Yeah, don't do it What one of your great cast members the fantastic the incredible Vince Vaughn who I just think the world of he gave me a great A great note once when I was trying to improvise doing a job with him.
对，对。对。那简直是你所能做的最糟糕的事情。而且那是一个很难给出的意见，那听起来像是怎样的？你会不会把人拉到一边，直接告诉他意见？对，“别试着去搞笑。那太烂了。”哇，对，“别那样做。”你的一位伟大的演员朋友，那个极其出色的文斯·沃恩——我对他的评价极高——有一次我在尝试和他一起即兴表演时，他给了我一个非常棒的建议。
We've done a couple of movies together. He was doing something genius and then I said something and he just stopped. He just looked at me and said, do you think that's helping? And I thought it was part of the dialogue, right? The improv. But it was not a character. It was part of the dialogue, right? The improv. It was not a character.
我们一起拍过几部电影。他当时在做一些天才般的表演，然后我说了句话，他就停下来了。他看着我，直接说：“你觉得这样有帮助吗？”我当时以为那是台词的一部分，对吧？是即兴发挥。但那不是角色在说话。那是台词的一部分，对吧？是即兴发挥。那不是角色。
It was Vince saying to Jason, shut your mouth and let me do my thing. And it was a good note. What a gut punch. But Larry, thanks for being here today. Hey Larry. Shawn, do you have an agenda you're trying to get to? I just want to ask him a question.
那是文斯在对杰森说：“闭上你的嘴，让我来发挥。”这真是一个很好的建议。这真是一个沉重的打击。不过，拉里，谢谢你今天能来。嘿，拉里。肖恩，你有什么想推进的议程吗？我只是想问他一个问题。
I haven't even gotten to the point yet that I feel so bummed out. Yeah, because I would have loved that environment so much. Larry, it's not over yet. It's not over. Larry, I'm going to fucking... I mean, I run into Larry on the golf course. I keep calling him Gary.
我甚至还没聊到点子上，就觉得自己太沮丧了。对，因为我本会非常喜欢那种环境的。拉里，还没结束呢。还没结束。拉里，我他妈的……我是说，我在高尔夫球场上碰到过拉里。我一直管他叫加里。
That's why I run into him on the golf course. Maybe that had something to do with it. I run into Larry on the golf course before and I've never been able to say it except for the one time when he asked me where I run into him on the golf course. Maybe that had something to do with it. I run into Larry on the golf course before and I've never been able to say it except for the one time when he asked me where I haven't been on, I was like, man, I really went, and it is one of my true regrets. I was like, that's an environment I feel like
这就是为什么我在高尔夫球场上碰到他。也许这跟那有点关系。我以前在高尔夫球场上碰到过拉里，除了那一次他问我我在高尔夫球场上哪儿碰到他之外，我从来没能说出口。也许这跟那有点关系。我以前在高尔夫球场上碰到过拉里，除了那一次他问我我在哪儿碰不到他，我当时就想，天哪，我真的去了，这成了我真正的遗憾之一。我当时就想，那种环境我觉得
I would have really liked. Because I like to fuck around. But anyway, so Larry, welcome to the podcast. Welcome to our show. How do you feel, scale of one to 10, how do you feel today about being here right now? Before I ever do anything, any show ever, I always regret that I said yes.
我真的会很喜欢。因为我喜欢瞎胡闹。不过不管怎样，拉里，欢迎来到播客。欢迎来到我们的节目。你觉得怎么样，在一到十的尺度上，你对此时此刻来到这里有什么感觉？在我做任何事、任何节目之前，我都总是会后悔自己答应了。
Yes. And I feel that way today. Of course. We're gonna get you to the other side of that by the time we're done. Okay, I hope so. Or not. Or it'll be worse. But are you good about saying no, or you are you terrible?
对。我今天就是这种感觉。当然。等我们结束的时候，我们会让你走出这种情绪的。好吧，希望如此。或者也可能不会。或者情况会更糟。不过你很擅长拒绝别人吗，还是说你特别不擅长？
Do you say yes because you don't want to you don't want to displease people No, I'm I'm good about saying no. Yeah good. That's a great quality. That's good. I mean Well, we had a friend who told us once look if you don't want to do it tomorrow, right? You someone says yeah in a few months, you know, you're like sure Yeah, no the better thing if you you don't wanna do it tomorrow, say no today, even if it's a couple months in the future. Larry, can we go back, Sean, can I grab the reins here for a second? Sure, yeah.
你答应是因为你不想让别人不高兴吗？不，我很擅长拒绝。对，很好。这是个极好的品质。那很好。我是说，有一次有个朋友告诉我们：“听着，如果你明天不想去，对吧？如果有人说几个月后的某天，你知道，你可能会说‘当然可以’。”不，更好的做法是，如果你明天不想去，今天就要拒绝，哪怕那是在几个月之后。拉里，我们能回到刚才的话题吗？肖恩，我能把主导权拿过来一会儿吗？当然，可以。
I'm gonna ask you, I kinda wanna, I know that you were a standup back in New York, you started sort of as a standup, right? And I know this from, I got kind of a history of you through our mutual friend Jim Valley, the great Jim Valley, who I adore. He lived in my building. And he lived in your building.
我要问你，我其实想，我知道你以前在纽约是个单口喜剧演员，你最初算是做单口喜剧起家的，对吧？我是通过一个渠道知道这一点的，我通过我们的共同朋友吉姆·瓦利大致了解了你的过去，那个我非常崇拜的伟大的吉姆·瓦利。他以前住在我的大楼里。而且他住在你的大楼里。
In New York. I remember him telling you stories about when Tanis's daughter was little and Jim was kind of a stay at home dad in a lot of ways, right? Yeah. And he would talk about you living in the building at Manhattan Plaza, right?
在纽约。我记得他跟我讲过一些故事，说当塔尼斯的女儿还小的时候，吉姆在很多方面算是个全职奶爸，对吧？对。他会说起你住在曼哈顿广场的那栋大楼里，对吧？
Right. What was that like being a standup back then? Like what was your kind of, what were your ambitions when you were doing that back in those days living in Manhattan Plaza and being a, did you want to be the world's greatest standup? I wanted to be a great standup. Yeah.
对。那时候做单口喜剧是什么感觉？比如你当时的心态是怎样的，你在做那个的时候有什么雄心壮志？住在曼哈顿广场做这个，你想成为世界上最伟大的单口喜剧演员吗？我想成为一个伟大的单口喜剧演员。对。
I wasn't, but I wanted to be one. And I really would have settled if you had told me in 1987 and you offered me $200 a week to do stand-up in New York, at the clubs, $200 a week for the rest of your life, I would have taken it. Wow. Wow. Wow. We have an offer for you.
我不是，但我很想成为那样的人。如果你在1987年告诉我，并提供给我每周200美元的报酬，让我在纽约的俱乐部里表演单口喜剧，每周200美元，管我一辈子，我真的会接受的。哇。哇。哇。我们现在有个工作要提供给你。
I had no hopes to do anything. Well, but what about, but you said, Sean said in the intro that you studied history to be a professor? No. No, no, just to get out of college. And that was world history or American history? Both.
我当时对做任何事都不抱什么希望。好吧，但是，你刚才说，肖恩在开场白里说你学历史是为了当教授？不。不，不，只是为了能从大学毕业。那是世界历史还是美国历史？两个都学。
Will loves himself some world history. I took history, I dropped out of college, but I was a history major and I love history. I read mainly. Yeah, I had no, I wasn't gonna, I wasn't interested in show business. Right. Really?
维尔最喜欢世界历史了。我学过历史，我后来从大学退学了，但我曾是个历史专业学生，我热爱历史。我主要是阅读。对，我没有，我当时不打算，我对演艺圈不感兴趣。真的吗？
Yeah. But dad, parents, by the way, Jewish by the way, both sides are just your father? It's a both, yeah. It's both, and grew up in the. He sounds so disappointed. I know. You know, if you would've split it up,
对。但是爸爸，父母，顺便问一下，犹太人吗？顺便问一下，两边都是，还是只有你父亲？两边都是，对。两边都是，而且在……他听起来好失望。我知道。你知道的，如果你当时各占一半的话，
I don't think it would've been the worst thing in the world. If you would have given me a half and half, I admire the halves. Sometimes somebody will tell me he's a half, and I'll go, oh, that's great, that's great. Yeah. So were either one of them particularly funny or funny enough for you to feel like,
我觉得也不是世界上最糟糕的事。如果你当时给我一个混血的身份，我很欣赏混血。有时有人会告诉我他是混血，我就会说：“哦，那太棒了，那太棒了。”所以他们俩中有人特别搞笑，或者搞笑到让你觉得，
oh, maybe I'll be a standup, I got it kind of in my genes? No. No. No. No. No. My mother was funny without trying to be funny, without realizing she was being funny. She had a kind of a Gracie Allen quality about her. In fact, my friends called my mother Gracie,
“哦，也许我会去说单口喜剧，这可能写在我的基因里”？没有。没有。没有。没有。没有。我母亲不用刻意搞笑就很搞笑，她自己都没意识到自己很搞笑。她身上有一种格雷西·艾伦式的特质。事实上，我的朋友们都叫我母亲格雷西，
but it wasn't purposeful. She wasn't cracking wise. Right. She wasn't cracking wise. Right. And we will be right back. Thanks to Viori for supporting the show. If you're sick and tired of traditional workout gear, Viori has you covered, literally. Everything has been designed to work out in,
但那不是故意的。她不是在抖机灵。对。她不是在抖机灵。对。我们马上回来。感谢Viori对本节目的支持。如果你对传统的健身服饰感到厌烦，Viori绝对能满足你的需求，字面意思上的满足。每一件衣服的设计都适合运动，
but doesn't look or feel like it. They've drawn inspiration from the coastal California lifestyle to create versatile pieces for everyday wear. We've been fans of URI for a long time as you've probably known so I'm excited to tell you why the men's Sunday Performance Jogger is one of my favorites. These joggers are made from premium recycled performance stretch fabric that offers equal parts of style and comfort. I love the Sunday Performance Jogger. I have it in cashmere heather but there's all these other colors like charcoal heather, dusty pine heather, ink heather, basically anything
但看起来和穿起来都不像运动服。他们从加州海岸的生活方式中汲取灵感，为日常穿着打造百搭的单品。正如你可能知道的那样，我们一直是Viori的长期粉丝，所以我很高兴向大家介绍为什么男士周日功能慢跑裤是我的最爱之一。这些慢跑裤采用优质回收功能弹力面料制成，兼具时尚感与舒适度。我超爱这款周日功能慢跑裤。我有一条羊绒混色款的，但还有所有这些其他颜色，像碳灰混色、灰绿混色、墨蓝混色，基本上所有
heather. If your name is heather please come over you'll be my favorite. Viori is an investment in your happiness and they're hooking up smartless listeners with 20% off your first purchase at viori.com smartless. That's v-u-o-r-i dot com smartless. That's V U O R I dot com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. We're brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter. So there, you know, whenever I go to New York, I always check out some Broadway shows. We're brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter. So there, you know, whenever I go to New York, I always check out some Broadway shows.
混色都有。如果你叫“混色”（Heather），请过来，你将成为我的最爱。投资Viori就是投资你的快乐，他们正在为SmartLess听众提供专属优惠：在viori.com/smartless首次购买可享8折优惠。网址是 v-u-o-r-i 点 com 斜杠 smartless。也就是 V-U-O-R-I 点 com 斜杠 smartless。你不仅能在首次购买时享受8折优惠，美国本土订单满75美元还可享受免运费和免费退货服务。快去 Viori.com/smartless 探索Viori服装的百搭魅力吧。本节目由ZipRecruiter部分赞助播出。所以你看，每当我去纽约时，我总是会去看一些百老汇演出。本节目由ZipRecruiter部分赞助播出。所以你看，每当我去纽约时，我总是会去看一些百老汇演出。
But before I come, I always get ahead of the game and I make sure I buy my tickets a month or two in advance. And so when you want the best, you have to act quickly or someone else will get it instead. It's like if you're hiring for your business, you want to find the most talented people for your open roles before the competition scoops them up. So what's the best way to do that? ZipRecruiter. ZipRecruiter finds qualified candidates fast. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis. ZipRecruiter's powerful matching technology takes center stage to identify top talent for your roles. Immediately after you post your job, ZipRecruiter's smart technology starts showing you qualified people for it.
但在我来之前，我总是未雨绸缪，确保提前一两个月把票买好。所以当你想要最好的东西时，你必须迅速行动，否则别人就会抢先一步。这就像如果你在为自己的公司招聘，你会在竞争对手把他们挖走之前，为你的空缺岗位找到最具才华的人。那么最好的方法是什么呢？ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter能快速找到合格的候选人。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartless 上免费试用。ZipRecruiter强大的匹配技术闪亮登场，为你的岗位精准识别顶尖人才。在你发布职位后，ZipRecruiter的智能技术会立即开始向你展示符合条件的人选。
Immediately after you post your job, ZipRecruiter's smart technology starts showing you qualified people for it. Amp up your hiring performance with ZipRecruiter and find the best fast. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try ZipRecruiter for free, ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis.
在你发布职位后，ZipRecruiter的智能技术会立即开始向你展示符合条件的人选。使用ZipRecruiter提升你的招聘效率，快速找到最优秀的人才。看看为什么五分之四在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。现在就访问这个专属网址免费试用ZipRecruiter：ziprecruiter.com/smartless。
Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. SmartLis is brought to you in part by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover.
再重复一遍，网址是 ziprecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。再重复一遍，网址是 ziprecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。SmartLess由Audible部分赞助播出。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有音频娱乐。你总能找到自己最爱的内容，或者发现全新的惊喜。
They offer an incredible selection of audio books across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, and tons more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. You know, I'm a huge Steve Martin fan, one of the reasons I got into the business, and I read his book years ago called Born Standing Up, and then when I saw it on A know, I'm a huge Steve Martin fan, one of the reasons I got into the business. And I read his book years ago called,
他们提供横跨各个流派的令人难以置信的有声书选择，从畅销书和新书上架到名人回忆录、悬疑与惊悚、励志与健康、商业等等，应有尽有。Audible是惊悚音频娱乐的目的地，为每一位热爱惊悚小说的听众提供备受期待的新书和下一本收听推荐。作为Audible会员，你可以从整个目录中每个月挑选一本永久保留的书籍，包括最新的畅销书和新书。你知道，我是史蒂夫·马丁的超级粉丝，这也是我进入这一行的原因之一，我多年前读过他写的一本书叫《生于单口》，后来当我在A你知道，我是史蒂夫·马丁的超级粉丝，这也是我进入这一行的原因之一。我多年前读过他写的一本叫作
"'Born Standing Up' and then when I saw it on Audible, I was like, oh my God, I have to hear Steve read it. And it's fantastic and it's even better than reading it. You get to listen to the guy, one of your idols actually read his book that you love. It's such a good book and such a fantastic, clever title, "'Born Standing Up' I love that.
《生于单口》的书，后来当我在Audible上看到它时，我当时就想：天哪，我必须听史蒂夫亲自朗读。这太棒了，甚至比阅读还要好。你可以听到你的偶像之一亲自朗读你喜爱的那本书。这是一本如此优秀的书，而且书名也如此绝妙、聪明，《生于单口》，我太喜欢了。
New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. And now back to the show.
新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。网址是 audible.com/smartless，或者发送短信 smartless 到 500-500 即可免费试用Audible 30天。Audible.com/smartless。现在让我们回到节目中。
After college you were in the Army Reserve? Yeah, because Vietnam was going on. And now back to the show. After college you were in the Army Reserve? Yeah, because Vietnam was going on. I didn't want to go, you know, I didn't want to go. And I signed up for the Reserves. And never got drafted? No, I never got drafted. But I got out of the Reserves after two years with a psychiatric discharge. Let's hear more about that. Yeah. Oh well I told this, I told this I think on Howard Stern.
大学毕业后你在陆军预备役待过？对，因为当时正值越南战争。现在让我们回到节目中。大学毕业后你在陆军预备役待过？对，因为当时正值越南战争。我不想去，你知道的，我不想去。所以我报名加入了预备役。后来从来没被征兵入伍？没有，我从来没被征兵。但我呆了两年后以精神病退伍的方式离开了预备役。让我们听听更多细节。好吧，我想我在霍华德·斯特恩的节目里讲过这个。
It's kind of a long story, but should I make a long story short? No, you can, we have a 45 minutes and a different audience. You've got a completely different audience. Yeah. If you're smart, this is the last answer you'll give. So good.
这有点说来话长，不过我是该长话短说吗？不，你可以，我们有45分钟时间，而且观众不一样。你面对的是完全不同的观众。对。如果你聪明的话，这是你给出的最后一个答案。太棒了。
Work the clock, Larry. Yeah. Challenge. And by the way, just make it up anyway. We're not going to check. No, I was in the Army, the Reserves. I went to basic training. It was horrendous.
看好时间，拉里。对。是个挑战。顺便说一句，不管怎样编造都行。我们不会去核实的。没有，我在军队里，在预备役。我去了基础训练。那太可怕了。
It was the worst experience of my life. I was ducking under live ammunition and firing weapons. Jumping over walls. And I had bayonets. So I did that for eight weeks and then I had occupational specialty school. I was a petroleum storage specialist. What?
那是我一生中最糟糕的经历。我得在实弹下低头躲避，还要开枪射击。跳过墙壁。还得拿刺刀。我就这样干了八周，然后参加了职业特长学校。我是个石油储存专家。什么？
And then we had to, yeah, it's a, well, you have to fill up the tanks with gas. Sure, sure. Somebody has to do it. So then, then after I got out, I had to go to meetings once a month at Floyd Bennett Field, a big airplane hangar, and it was freezing and I had to go home and I stayed at my apartment
然后我们必须，对，这是一个，嗯，你必须给油箱加油。当然，当然。总得有人干这个。所以然后，在我退伍之后，我每个月必须去弗洛伊德·贝内特机场开一次会，在一个巨大的飞机机库里，冷得要死，然后我得回家，我待在我的公寓里
My parents apartment in Brooklyn. I stayed with them for Saturday Friday nights and Saturday night and then I'd go home back to New York on Sunday And but the meetings were Saturday and Sunday and then I heard about a psychiatrist who was writing letters To get people out. So I borrowed $250, I went to see the psychiatrist, I convinced him that I was insane, he wrote me a letter saying I was insane. You gotta, stop there.
我父母在布鲁克林的公寓。我周五晚上和周六晚上住在他们那里，然后周日回纽约，但开会是在周六和周日，后来我听说有一个精神病医生在给人写信，好让人家退役。所以我借了250美元，去看了那个精神病医生，我让他相信我疯了，他给我写了一封信，说我疯了。你得停一下。
How do you convince him you're insane? What was your flavor? My flavor was I wanted to kill myself. Okay, so you went in there and you really tried to be convincingly... Yeah, I had suicidal ruminations. What was it you were trying to get rid of? What were you trying to avoid? Life was just too hard.
你是怎么让他相信你疯了的？你当时演的是哪种疯？我演的是我想自杀。好吧，所以你走进去，真的很努力地去表现得令人信服……对，我有自杀倾向。你当时想摆脱什么？你当时想逃避什么？生活实在是太艰难了。
Were you able to make yourself cry? I was able to act. I was able to act it. Yeah, you can see it on Max right now. I think I could have fooled... I don't know if I fooled him, because everybody was acting for him. But when I went to the meeting
你能让自己哭出来吗？我能演。我能演出来。对，你现在在Max（流媒体平台）上还能看到呢。我觉得我能骗过……我不知道我有没有骗过他，因为每个人都在他面前演戏。但当我带着那封信去开会时，
armed with the letter, now I'm really acting insane. And these people who knew me for two years, because I went off into the corner, I was huddled, I was by myself, I was looking around, acting crazy. And I said, where? Rocking back and forth a little bit, good, good. Still rolling.
现在我真的在装疯卖傻了。那些认识了我两年的人——因为我躲到角落里，缩成一团，孤零零的，四处张望，表现得像个疯子。然后我说，在哪儿？身体还前后微微晃动，很好，很好。还在继续。
Where's the major? I can't, where's the major? I need to talk to the major, where's the major? Yeah. And so somebody... And I saw people pointing at me, talking about me. I know they were... Because you're nuts.
少校在哪里？我不能，少校在哪里？我需要跟少校谈谈，少校在哪里？对。然后有人……我看到有人指着我，在议论我。我知道他们在……因为你太疯狂了。
Like, what was going on with me? And then I went to see the major, and I gave him the letter, and he read the letter, and I'm sitting across from him, acting as nutty as a fruitcake, and... You should have chewed off a corner of the letter and I'm sitting across from him acting as nutty as a fruitcake and um... You should have chewed off a corner of the letter.
就像，我当时是怎么回事？然后我去见了少校，把信交给了他，他看了信，我坐在他对面，装得像个神经病一样，还有……你应该把信的一角给咬下来。我坐在他对面，装得像个神经病一样，还有……你应该把信的一角给咬下来。
Well, he had the letter. He read the letter. He asked me a couple of questions after the letter and then he said to me, can you drive home? Yeah, perfect. You knew you'd done it. And I knew. I knew I had him.
好吧，他拿着信。他读了信。信看完后他问了我几个问题，然后对我说：“你能开车回家吗？”对，完美。你知道你成功了。我知道。我知道我拿捏住他了。
I said, I said, oh yeah, yeah, I'm a done it. I knew I had him. I said, oh yeah, yeah, I'm a good driver. I'm a good driver. Wow. That's crazy. Wow. Now you're not old enough to go to Vietnam. I tell you what, we could have used some of that kind of ingenuity in Vietnam. Now I'm just saying, we could have used people who had thought... The country could have used you. Yeah, the country could have used it, Larry. I'm sure I could have made a contribution in some way.
我说，我说：“哦，对，对，我行。”我知道我拿捏住他了。我说：“哦，对，对，我是个好司机。我是个好司机。”哇。太疯狂了。现在你还没到去越南的年龄。我跟你说，我们在越南时本来可以利用那种机智的。我只是说说，我们本可以利用那些动过脑筋的人……国家本来可以重用你的。对，国家本可以重用它的，拉里。我确信我在某种程度上能做出贡献。
Yeah, but look at the contribution you ended up making here. Wonderful, Larry. But Larry, now that you're here on this little smart list thing, and we didn't get a chance to really go deep on the set when I was working with you on Curb, like, I always wanted to ask you,
对，但看看你最后做出的贡献。太棒了，拉里。不过拉里，既然你来到了这个小小的SmartList节目，而且我们在拍《抑制热情》时我跟你合作的时候，我们没有机会深入交流——我一直想问你，
I wanted to ask you the questions those days that we worked together, but I was too embarrassed. Like, I know you're probably sick of talking about it, but Seinfeld, I've always wondered, how did you and Jerry even meet? And how did that happen? Because when you make a TV show,
当年我们一起工作时，我其实很想问你那些问题，但我太尴尬了。就像，我知道你可能已经厌烦谈论这个了，但关于《宋飞正传》，我一直很好奇，你和杰瑞是怎么认识的？这事是怎么发生的？因为当你制作一部电视剧时，
it's so rare that the talent and the writers or the showrunners, that everything kind of hooks up and everybody has the same sensibility. And it hooks up and everybody has the same sensibility. And it seems you and Jerry had the same sensibility. So did you know each other out or was that like a business, like set up meeting or something? We were both comedians in New York. And so you knew each other.
很少有这样的情况：才华横溢的演员、编剧或剧集运作人，所有这些要素完美契合，大家的审美趣味完全一致。契合在一起，而且每个人都有相同的审美。看起来你和杰瑞有着相同的审美。所以你们俩本来就认识，还是说那像是一次商务的、刻意安排的见面之类的？我们俩当时都是纽约的喜剧演员。所以你们互相认识。
So we knew each other in New York. He generally performed at the comic strip. I was at the improv, but we would see each other a lot. We always enjoyed each other's company. We would actually go and write together in the afternoon. He'd bring his premises, I'd bring my premises, and we'd go over them. And I had written a screenplay that somehow he had read.
所以我们在纽约就互相认识。他通常在喜剧细胞（Comic Strip）表演。我在即兴喜剧俱乐部（Improv），但我们经常见面。我们总是很享受彼此的陪伴。我们实际上会相约在下午一起写段子。他带他的喜剧前提来，我带我的喜剧前提来，然后我们一起讨论。我当时写了一个剧本，他不知怎么的读过了。
And then when NBC approached him about doing a show, I had written a screenplay that somehow he had read. And then when NBC approached him about doing a show, he came to me and asked if I'd be interested in working with it. Had you written a half hour script before? No. No. That's why it's so damn good.
然后当NBC接洽他制作一档节目时，我当时写了一个剧本，不知怎么的被他读过了。然后当NBC接洽他制作一档节目时，他找到我，问我有没有兴趣一起合作。你以前写过半小时的剧本吗？没有。没有。这就是为什么它那么该死的好看。
It's just so different in form. But did you, so when you get into that, started writing that half hour multicam format. Wait a second, wait a second. I did write one half hour, I did write a half hour pilot for Gilbert Gottfried. No kidding. Yeah, that was filmed and they didn't pick it up.
它的形式太不一样了。但是你，当你开始涉足并编写那个半小时的多机位格式时。等等，等等。我确实写过一个半小时的，我为吉尔伯特·戈特弗雷德写过一个半小时的试播集。不是吧。是的，那是拍了但没被选中。
That was for HBO. Was it also sort of changing the format a bit? No? Yeah. Yeah, they didn't like it. Sorry, Willie. Well, I was just gonna say, so I kinda wanna get into this half-hour format.
那是为HBO拍的。当时是不是也算稍微改变了一下形式？没有吗？对。是的，他们不喜欢。对不起，威利。噢，我刚才只是想说，所以我挺想聊聊这个半小时格式的。
So you do multicam, but the way that you do Seinfeld, it's not like traditional multicam, because you have, right, well, at least initially, you kind of would go back and forth to Jerry doing his standup, and then you guys kind of fine tune that as you went, is my recollection, again. Right. But then-
所以你拍的是多机位，但你做《宋飞传》的方式，跟传统多机位不一样，因为你们，对吧，至少一开始，你们会经常切来切去拍杰瑞做单口喜剧，然后随着节目的推进，你们一直在微调，如果我没记错的话。没错。但是然后——
The premise of the show, the premise of the show initially, was how does a comedian get his material. So we would go through an episode and you would see whatever happened to him on the show, he would turn into material. That was like the idea. And then it went like after the first year,
节目的最初构思，节目的最初构思是，一个喜剧演员是如何取材的。所以我们会看一集节目，你在节目里看到他遭遇了什么，他就会把这些变成喜剧素材。当时就是这个想法。然后过了一年之后，
you guys tossed that, right? I don't think after the first year. I think it was a couple of years. And then you just kind of moved it to the end. Yeah, right. But did you, again, I don't want to get too in the weeds on the format. No, go in the weeds.
你们就把这个废了，对吧？我觉得不是一年后。我觉得是几年后。然后你们就把这个环节移到了最后。对，没错。但是你，再说一次，我不想在这个形式上纠缠太深。不，你尽管纠缠。
But we're already in the weeds. Did you enjoy it? I don't know, was it difficult for you writing in that format? Was it a format that you liked or that you had to get used to or that you rebelled against? that you liked or that you had to get used to or that you rebelled against? No, I was okay with it.
但我们已经纠缠进去了。你喜欢这种形式吗？我不知道，用这种形式写作对你来说很难吗？这是你喜欢的形式，还是你不得不去适应的，或者你是带着反叛心理去做的？是你喜欢的，还是你不得不去适应的，或者你是带着反叛心理去做的？不，我挺能接受的。
I didn't mind it at all. At one point I said to him, I can't believe they're letting us do this. I was really surprised. Really? Yeah, I felt like, how are we getting away with this? Why are you letting us do this? Did you have a staff that you handpicked
我一点也不介意。有一次我对他说，我真不敢相信他们竟然让我们这么干。我真的很吃惊。真的吗？对，我觉得，我们怎么能蒙混过关的？你们凭什么让我们这么干？你们当时有没有一个精挑细选的编剧团队，
or did they try to marry you with a bunch of more traditional writers and how did that all work out? Well, for the first four shows, I wasn't the executive producer. Yeah. They brought in someone who had experience. Sure.
还是说他们试图把你们和一群更传统的编剧凑在一块儿？这一切是怎么运作的？好吧，前四集的时候，我并不是执行制片人。对。他们请来了一个有经验的人。当然。
And who had a show on the air previously. And they brought him in. And he was my boss. Right. And so we handed in the first couple of shows. And then we were called into his office for notes. And he just, it was just four episodes. That note meeting, it did not go well.
而且他以前做过播出的节目。他们把他请来了。他就是我的老板。没错。然后我们交了前几集剧本。接着我们被叫进他的办公室听修改意见。结果，那才只有四集。那次意见反馈会，很不顺利。
We just generally probably wanted to make it something It did not go well. It just generally probably wanted to make it something a bit less specific. Less esoteric? I don't know. They were probably going for something more traditional, something more familiar, recognizable, because you're a major network and let's round the edges a bit. And you guys, thankfully, said, well, but,
我们大概只是想把它弄得……结果很不顺利。它大概只是想让它变得不那么具体。不那么深奥？我不知道。他们可能想要更传统、更熟悉、更容易识别的东西，因为你们是一个主流电视台，所以我们要把棱角磨平一点。而你们，谢天谢地，却说，好吧，但是，
because you guys famously did not start high up in the ratings, you were probably figuring, what, give us a chance to grow and do our own thing. I said no to everything he said. Yeah. Right. I said, I'm not gonna, I can't do that. And then I, you know, I was, and. I'm not gonna I can't I can't do that and then I can then I you know, I was and then I quit and and
因为你们一开始的收视率其实并不高，这是出了名的，你们当时大概在想，什么，给我们一个成长并做我们自己的机会。他对我说的一切都说了不。对。没错。我说，我不会，我做不到那个。然后我，你知道的，我当时，然后我——我不会，我做不到，我做不到那个，然后我，然后我，你知道的，我当时，然后我辞职了，然后——
They said Jared and then Jerry went to Castle Rock. It said look forget it We're gonna even do this or not. And and so then that was that guy didn't really participate after that Yeah, and it was it was essentially it was essentially my show after that. Yeah. Larry, and it should be noted, I was a fan of Jerry's, I saw him when I was like 17, my buddies got me for my birthday to go see Jerry play
他们说，杰瑞，然后杰瑞去了城堡摇滚公司。他们说，听着，算了吧，我们要么拍这个，要么不拍。然后，那个家伙在那之后就没怎么参与了。对，在那之后，它基本上，基本上就是我的节目了。对。拉里，顺便提一下，我是杰瑞的粉丝，我大概17岁时看过他的演出，我的死党们买票作为生日礼物带我去看的，杰瑞在
in Toronto in a theater. Oh no? Yeah, and I was a really big fan of his standup, and so when you guys started the show, I watched for a season, I had just moved to New York. It was the fall of 90, right, when you guys came on the air? I think that's when, or summer, maybe?
多伦多的一个剧院里演出。真的吗？对，我非常喜欢他的单口喜剧，所以当你们开始做这个节目时，我看了第一季，我刚搬到纽约。那是90年秋天，对吧，你们开播的时候？我想那是，或者夏天，也许吧？
The summer. Summer of 90, yeah, summer of 90. The pilot came on in the summer of 89, and then the first four shows came on in June of 90. Yeah, and so crazy. So crazy. And it was the Seinfeld Chronicles, as everybody knows, right?
夏天。90年夏天，对吧，90年夏天。试播集在89年夏天播出，然后前四集在90年6月播出。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。这就是《宋飞传》，大家都知道的，对吧？
Yeah, the first season, yeah. First season. And they were? Or just the pilot, I think. I think it was just the pilot. Oh, was it? I don't remember, yeah. And I seem to remember,
对，第一季，对。第一季。他们是？或者只是试播集，我想。我想应该只是试播集。噢，是吗？我不记得了，对。而且我依稀记得，
I think we talked about this maybe when Jerry was on, that the budget for the show at NBC came out of late night. Right? That initially it was Rick Ludwin who... I think Variety. Oh, Variety, Variety, yeah. And right, was it?
我想我们可能在杰瑞来的时候聊过这个，NBC节目的预算其实是从深夜档里出的。对吧？最初是里克·拉德温他……我想是综艺。噢，综艺，综艺，对。没错，是吗？
Rick Ludwin. Yeah, one of the greats. He championed the show. Great dude. The show wouldn't have gotten on the air if not for him. I love that. And by the way, while you were on Seinfeld, you had both your daughters or just one daughter?
里克·拉德温。对，最伟大的人物之一。他支持了这个节目。是个好人。如果没有他，这个节目根本无法播出。我太喜欢这个了。话说回来，你在拍《宋飞传》的时候，你两个女儿都出生了还是只有一个女儿？
No, both. Both, wow. And did you bring them around? Were they interested? No, they were babies. No, I know, but when they got older? When they got older, it was off the air. First of all, don't, yeah.
不，两个都有。两个都有，哇。你把她们带到片场过吗？她们感兴趣吗？没有，她们当时还是婴儿。不，我懂，但她们长大后呢？她们长大后，节目已经停播了。首先，别，对。
Sean, you stupid son of a... I thought they were like... Sean, take a time out. Real quick. Did the show do well with babies? Sean, the show went off in 98. My daughter, Kazzie, was born in 94. Oh, okay.
肖恩，你这个大笨蛋……我以为她们是……肖恩，暂停一下。说真的。这节目对带婴儿友好吗？肖恩，这节目98年就停播了。我女儿卡兹是94年出生的。噢，好吧。
And Romney was born in 96. First of all, calm down. Larry, how did you guys do with like toddlers? Did you guys get a lot of toddlers? Yeah. Oh yeah. So, but Larry, Curb, correct me, has been on longer than Seinfeld was?
罗姆尼是96年出生的。首先，冷静点。拉里，你们拍的时候周围有很多幼儿吗？你们遇到过很多幼儿吗？有啊。哦，是的。所以，不过拉里，《抑制热情》，纠正我一下，它播出的时间比《宋飞传》还长吧？
Curb has been on for 24 years. 24 years, isn't that amazing? Not, not consecutively. No, not consecutively. You take like 10 years off. But when we started, we started. Holy shit. Wait, I wanna go into Curb like 10 years off. But when we started, we started. Holy shit. Wait, I wanna go into Curb More
《抑制热情》已经播了24年了。24年，这不是很惊人吗？不是，不是连续播的。不，不是连续播的。你中间休息了大概10年。但我们一开始，我们就。天哪。等等，我想多聊聊《抑制热情》中间休息10年。但我们一开始，我们就。天哪。等等，我想多聊聊《抑制热情》，
because how did you come up with the, like being there, I was like, oh, this is how this works. You get like a little outline for my sister Tracy who doesn't understand. It's not written like, say Seinfeld was. It's all improvised like we were talking at the beginning of this episode. That, but how did you?
因为你是怎么想出这种模式的，身临其境时我就在想，噢，原来是这么运作的。你会拿到一个小纲要，就像我妹妹特蕾西不理解的那样。它不像《宋飞传》那样写好了台词。它全都是即兴的，就像我们这集节目开始时聊的那样。那个，但你是怎么……
It's a story outline. The story outline, yeah, so you have to hit those points. But it's so fun because you spend an hour just improvising one scene, and then you cut out the fat in the editing room, and you have all great stuff. It's such a great format. So who thought of that, and why did you think of that? I heard once, because when you and I did the three stooges,
这是一个故事大纲。故事大纲，对，所以你必须踩中那些点。但它太有趣了，因为你花一个小时只为即兴表演一个场景，然后在剪辑室里删掉废话，剩下的就全都是好东西。这真是一种绝佳的模式。那谁想出这个的？你为什么会这么想？我曾经听说过，因为当年你和我拍《三个活宝》时，
you said to me, I hate memorizing lines. Yeah. Well, it was, Seinfeld had ended, the three stooges, you said to me I hate memorizing lines. Yeah. Yeah. Well, it was, Seinfeld had ended, and I was thinking about what I was gonna do next, and Jeff Garland had, I had an office at Castle Rock, and Jeff Garland had an office next door, and he said to me, what are you gonna do now?
你对我说，我讨厌背台词。对。好吧，当时，《宋飞传》已经结束了，拍《三个活宝》时，你对我说我讨厌背台词。对。对。好吧，当时，《宋飞传》已经结束了，我在考虑接下来要做什么，杰夫·加兰在城堡摇滚公司有间办公室，而杰夫·加兰的办公室就在隔壁，他对我说，你现在打算做什么？
I said, I'm thinking about going back to standup, and he said, well, you should film it. Uh-huh. And then I thought me, what are you going to do now? I said, I'm thinking about going back to stand-up. And he said, well, you should film it. And then I thought about, oh, well, what is that going to be? Filming it, that sounds intrusive. I don't know. What are they going to do? The camera's going to follow me into a dry cleaner? I could understand.
我说，我在考虑回去做单口喜剧，他说，那你应该把它拍下来。呃-哈。然后我想——我，你现在打算做什么？我说，我在考虑回去做单口喜剧。他说，那你应该把它拍下来。然后我开始想，噢，那会是什么样呢？把它拍下来，听起来像是侵犯隐私。我不知道。他们会怎么做？摄像机会跟着我进干洗店吗？我能理解
I could see how it's going to be on stage. That could be somewhat interesting to see the growth of the act from beginning to end. But offstage, I didn't like the idea of filming myself, cameras following me around, I didn't feel I'm all that interesting to follow. And so I thought maybe if I wrote some fictitious stories, that we could do that around the stand-up.
在舞台上会是什么样。看一个表演从无到有的成长过程，可能会有点意思。但在舞台下，我不太喜欢把自己拍下来，摄像机整天跟着我，我不觉得我有什么值得别人跟踪拍摄的价值。所以我想，也许如果我写一些虚构的故事，围绕着单口喜剧来展开，那就行了。
The stand-up could be real, but the offstage stuff would be just stuff I made up. And so that's what I did. I wrote an outline. I made Jeff my manager. Cheryl auditioned. She was my wife. We had kids in the first special,
单口喜剧可以是真的，但台下发生的那些事全都是我编的。这就是我所做的。我写了一份大纲。我让杰夫当我的经纪人。谢丽尔来试镜了。她演我的妻子。我们在第一部特辑里就有孩子了，
because that's what it was. It was a special. It had kids in the first special, because that's what it was. It was a special, it wasn't a pilot. It was just a one-off special. Right, we got it. And, did you get it? Or should I repeat it one more time? I just can't wait to hear what happened to the kids.
因为本来就是这样。那是一部特辑。它在第一部特辑里就有孩子，因为本来就是这样。那是一部特辑，不是试播集。它只是一部单次播出的特辑。没错，我们懂了。而且，你懂了吗？还是我需要再重复一遍？我简直等不及想知道孩子们怎么了。
Well, I didn't really want to see the kids, I realized after the special. How did you off the children? I just pretended the first show never existed. Never happened, that's the best way to do it. I love stuff like that. You never need to fucking explain it. No, no, no, you don't need to explain everything, right? I love that. Just fucking changed it.
好吧，拍完特辑后我意识到，我其实并不想看到孩子。你怎么把孩子们弄走的？我只是假装第一集从来没存在过。从来没发生过，这是最好的处理方式。我太喜欢这种套路了。你根本不需要他妈的解释。不，不，不，你不需要解释一切，对吧？我太喜欢了。直接他妈的改掉。
I didn't want kids in the show. I just thought the show would be so much funnier without kids. I didn't want to deal with kids. I didn't want to in the show. I just thought the show would be so much funnier without kids. I didn't want to deal with kids. I didn't want to keep having to explain, what about the kids? Where are the kids? Who's watching the kids? I didn't want to have to keep justifying everything
我不想在节目里有孩子。我只是觉得没有孩子的节目要搞笑得多。我不想应付小孩子。我不想在节目里……我只是觉得没有孩子的节目要搞笑得多。我不想应付小孩子。我不想一直解释，孩子们呢？孩子们在哪？谁在看孩子？我不想一直去合理化所有
that was going on and having to explain where the kids were. Right. Kids aren't funny. Kids aren't funny. Hey, the other thing is, Larry, do you think, God, you did something really genius, which is, you were able to play this version of yourself, if you will, and you get to sort of be cranky and say whatever you want.
发生的事情，还得解释孩子们都去哪了。没错。小孩子一点也不好笑。小孩子一点也不好笑。嘿，还有一件事，拉里，你觉得，天哪，你做了一件真正天才的事，那就是，你可以扮演这样一个你自己，如果你愿意这么说的话，你可以有点暴躁，想说什么就说什么。
And has it, it must have, God, I'm so envious, it just bled into your real life that you're able to now, because people just buy it, and they're like, it's just Larry being Larry. He's like from the show. And now you can just, you can go to a gas station and give a guy the finger and like people will laugh. See you later. Or scream at the slow group in front of you.
而且这，这肯定，天哪，我太嫉妒了，它已经渗入到你的现实生活中了，以至于你现在可以，因为大家完全买账，他们会觉得，这不就是拉里在做自己嘛。他就像节目里那样。现在你甚至可以去加油站对别人竖中指，而大家还会哈哈大笑。回头见。或者对着前面那群慢吞吞的人大喊大叫。
Yeah, you can do whatever the fuck you want on this planet. I mean, I don't know about the planet, but like the west side of LA and Manhattan, you could do whatever the fuck you want. It's made my life so much better. Jesus fucking Christ, now I'm jealous. I'm really getting heated now.
对，在这个星球上你想他妈的干什么都行。我是说，我不确定是不是整个星球，但比如西洛杉矶和曼哈顿，你想他妈的干什么都行。这让我的生活好过太多了。他妈的耶稣基督，我现在开始嫉妒了。我现在真的有点上火了。
When I realized this fucking carte blanche, you literally printed yourself a carte blanche to say whatever the fuck you want in the places that we... And people are disappointed if I'm not that way. I know! People are like, fuck the guy paid his bill and he didn't tell me to go fuck myself.
当我意识到这张该死的空白支票时，你简直是给自己打印了一张空白支票，可以在我们……的地方想他妈的说什么就说什么，而且如果我不是那样，大家反而会失望。我懂！大家会觉得，操，那家伙付了账，居然没有让我去吃自己。
I mean, what am I doing wrong? He must hate me. You're making the people happy by you being cranky. It's so great. Yeah. But do you notice that honestly, that you get some stuff out there as this sort of this other version of yourself,
我是说，我到底哪里做错了？他一定恨死我了。你用你的暴躁让大家开心了。这太棒了。对。但你有没有发现，说实话，你把这部分内容通过另一个版本的自己展现出去之后，
and then your real life actually ends up being a little bit more placid and less dramatic? I haven't noticed that, but it is acting and doing that Larry David on the show. Yeah. It is so much fun, first of all, and kind of a little cathartic in a way. I know what you mean. A little cathartic in a way. I know what you mean.
其实你现实中的生活反而变得更加平静、戏剧性更少了？我没注意到这一点，但是在节目里演那个拉里·戴维，
Because you keep. A little cathartic in a way, a way to couch it. I mean, what are you talking, obviously, it's the fucking greatest. You get to say all these horrible things. By the way, how about, I wasn't even gonna bring this up, but it just hit me, Marjorie Taylor Greene, first of all, she said she was watching
首先太有趣了，而且在某种程度上有点宣泄的作用。我懂你的意思。在某种程度上有点宣泄的作用。我懂你的意思。因为你一直。在某种程度上有点宣泄的作用，算是一种情感宣泄的出口。我的意思是，你在说什么，显而易见，这他妈太棒了。你可以说所有这些可怕的话。顺便说一句，还有，我甚至都不想提起这个，但它突然击中了我，玛乔丽·泰勒·格林，首先，她说她在看
Curb Your Enthusiasm, which is already kind of, oh, you watched the show, she said she was watching Curb Your Enthusiasm, which is already kind of, oh, you watched the show. And then she got upset because she thought you painted people in her state or in the South as racist or whatever, I'm paraphrasing, so I don't know her words. But weren't you kind of blown away that she even watches your show? I was pretty surprised by it.
《抑制热情》，这本身就已经有点，哦，你居然看这个节目，她说她在看《抑制热情》，这本身就已经有点，哦，你居然看这个节目。然后她很不高兴，因为她觉得你把她那个州或者南方的人刻画成种族主义者或者别的什么，我在意译，所以我不确定她的原话。但她居然看你的节目，你难道不觉得有点震惊吗？我确实挺惊讶的。
But it was just about a law that exists in that state. Right. Exactly. Where you can't give people water or food or when they're in line voting. It's just outrageous. It's so unbelievable. It's so stupid. It's so great. Yeah, I remember when I heard about that law, I wrote it down in my notebook. And then I knew I was going gonna, you had to use that.
但那只是关于那个州现行的一项法律。没错。没错。就是排队投票时不能给人们水或食物。这简直太离谱了。太不可思议了。太蠢了。太棒了。对，我听到那条法律的时候，把它记在了我的笔记本上。然后我知道我一定要，你得用上这个。
The whole season is like kind of around that, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah, it's great. So then Larry, so the show has had this incredible, long, successful run. You've brought it to this beautiful conclusion. I'm not gonna ask you what's next, but I would imagine that you're good, right? You've worked your nards off for however many years at a really high level, accomplished probably 10 times what you thought you would accomplish. You feel satisfied.
整季节目基本上都是围绕这个展开的，对吧？对。对，太棒了。所以拉里，这个节目取得了难以置信的、长期的巨大成功。你把它带向了一个完美的结局。我不会问你接下来有什么打算，但我猜你现在过得很惬意吧？不管多少年，你在极高的水平上拼尽全力工作，取得的成就可能十倍于你当初的预期。你感到满足了，
you feel satisfied, are there areas in your life that you would love to try to find equal success in, or other areas of the business, or different industries? No. No, you're good. You're all set. Any other industries you wanna get into? I'd love to be an offensive coordinator for an NFL team.
你感到满足了，在你生活的其他领域，你有没有想过去寻找同等程度的成功，或者商业上的其他领域，或者不同的行业？没有。没有，你很满意了。还有什么想涉足的行业吗？我很想成为NFL球队的进攻协调员。
That would be my dream job. Very offensive coordinator. But truly, you do love football, and specifically, do you know about plays and all that stuff? No, I don't know anything about it, but I feel like I could get at it. Yeah, I know nothing.
那将是我梦寐以求的工作。非常有攻击性的进攻协调员。但说真的，你确实热爱橄榄球，尤其是，你懂战术和那些东西吗？不，我什么都不懂，但我觉得我能上手。对，我什么都不懂。
But I feel like if I studied it, if somebody took me under their wing, I feel like in a year or two, I could design, I feel I could design great plays. It's a creative endeavor really when you think about it. From what I understand, if you just play Madden, you really learn quite a bit. So maybe try that, gets yourself a playstation.
但我觉得如果我研究一下，如果有谁能带带我，我觉得在一两年内，我能设计，我觉得我能设计出伟大的战术。仔细想想，这其实是一项极具创造力的工作。据我所了解的，如果你只是玩《麦登橄榄球》，你真的能学到不少东西。所以也许可以试试这个，给自己买个PlayStation。
Oh really, oh no, I've never done that. Could you imagine Larry David on the field just calling shots? Yeah, throwing his headset. With the little headset, screaming into that thing? I honestly feel I can do it. You'd say, you'd just be yelling like, just throw it and then catch it.
噢真的吗？噢不，我从没玩过。你能想象拉里·戴维在球场上运筹帷幄吗？对，摔耳机。戴着小耳机，对着那东西大喊大叫？我老实觉得我能行。你会说，你只会大喊大叫，比如，直接传球然后接住！
How hard is it? What team would that be? Would that be the Giants or the Jets? Well, you know, I'm a Jet fan. I'm also a Giant fan, but I'm more Jets than Giants. When Joe Namath came in in 1965, I really took to him and so I became a Jet fan. Larry, you know, when we were working together,
有多难？那是哪支球队？是巨人队还是喷气机队？好吧，你知道的，我是喷气机队的球迷。我也喜欢巨人队，但我比起巨人更喜欢喷气机。1965年乔·纳马特加盟时，我真的很喜欢他，所以我成了喷气机队的球迷。拉里，你知道的，我们以前合作时，
I asked you the same kind of thing Jason was asking. I'm like, why are you ending? Why are you stopping the show? And you just said, look at me, I asked you the same kind of thing Jason was asking. I'm like, why are you ending? Why are you stopping the show? And you just said, look at me, I'm 76 years old. Look at me. What do you mean? You're in incredible shape. I know the way you take care of yourself.
我问过你和杰森刚才问的类似的问题。我说，你为什么要把节目完结？为什么要停播？你当时就说，看着我，我问过你和杰森刚才问的类似的问题。我说，你为什么要把节目完结？为什么要停播？你当时就说，看着我，我都76岁了。看着我。什么意思？你现在的状态好得不得了。我知道你平时多注重保养。
You eat great, you exercise, you're out there every day. 76, when's your birthday, by the way? Quick, July 2nd. Do you hate, by the way, do you hate birthdays? You hate holidays? Well, I hate, you know, it becomes a job returning the birthday emails and the texts. I agree.
你饮食健康，经常锻炼，每天都在外面活动。76岁，你生日是什么时候来着？快说，7.2。顺便问一句，你讨厌生日吗？你讨厌节假日吗？嗯，我讨厌，你知道的，回复生日邮件和短信变成了一项工作。我同意。
It's a bit of a job. So yeah, I don't like it. I really don't like it. You know what I don't like is when people sing happy birthday to me. I don't know what to do. It's the worst, like, minute and a half. All you can do is make a face and shake your head.
这确实有点像一份工作。所以是的，我不喜欢。我真的很不喜欢。你知道我最讨厌什么吗？别人对我唱生日快乐歌。我不知道该怎么办。那是极其难熬的、漫长的一分半钟。你唯一能做的就是挤出一个表情然后摇摇头。
Yeah. It's a weird. Wait, a half. All you can do is make a face and shake your head. Yeah. It's a weird. Wait, what about all the other holidays? I get the birthday thing, it becomes a job. I detest all holidays. Detest them. Not one. Not one.
对。这很诡异。等等，半分钟。你唯一能做的就是挤出一个表情然后摇摇头。对。这很诡异。等等，那其他节日呢？我理解生日，那变成了一项工作。我痛恨所有节日。痛恨。一个不留。一个都没有。
There's not one holiday that I like. Wait, what about? I particularly hate Halloween. I hate Thanksgiving. I hate Christmas. New Year's I can stand, I hate Thanksgiving, I hate Christmas. New Year's I can stand because I know that the whole thing's gonna be over soon after that. Yeah, but you gotta stay up late.
没有一个节日是我喜欢的。等等，那……我尤其讨厌万圣节。我讨厌感恩节。我讨厌圣诞节。新年我还能忍，我讨厌感恩节，我讨厌圣诞节。新年我还能忍，因为我知道这一切很快就会过去。对，但你得熬夜。
No, I haven't stayed up past 12 and 15 years. Why Halloween? Because you gotta dress up. The costumes, the kids, the bothering, you know. You're knocking on the door. By the way, my house is... My house is in darkness on Halloween. Of course it is.
不，我已经15年没熬过夜超过12点半了。为什么讨厌万圣节？因为你得盛装打扮。那些服装、小孩子们、烦人的事，你知道的。他们在敲门。顺便说一句，我的房子……万圣节期间我的房子是一片漆黑的。那是当然。
All the lights are out. Walking around candles. Nobody knocks on the door. We put a sign out that says, sorry, no candy every single year. So they just keep walking. Mary, you could probably get away with putting a sign that said go fuck yourself They'd fucking build you a goddamn monument, I'm still really grinding on this Yeah, I remember I've seen you at Conan's Christmas party a couple times
所有的灯都关着。拿着蜡烛走来走去。没有人会来敲门。我们每年都会挂出一个牌子，上面写着：抱歉，没有糖果。所以他们就直接走过去了。拉里，你大概可以直接挂个牌子上面写着“去你妈的”，大家甚至会为你建一座该死的纪念碑呢。我还在纠结这个。对，我记得我曾在柯南的圣诞派对上见过你几次，
And it's great. Yeah, but and that's that's a do you like going to parties? Well, that's that's kind of like it's not a dinner party, but they served great, and that's, do you like going to parties? Well that's kind of like, it's not a dinner party, but they serve great food and stuff, but I imagine you don't like to sit down at dinner parties, or do you? The thing about the dinner party is you don't know who's going. That's right.
挺棒的。对，而那个是——你喜欢去派对吗？好吧，那有点像，虽然不是晚宴，但他们提供很棒的食物之类的。而那个是——你喜欢去派对吗？好吧，那有点像，虽然不是晚宴，但他们提供很棒的食物之类的。但我猜你肯定不喜欢坐着吃晚宴，对吧？晚宴最烦人的地方在于你根本不知道都有谁会去。没错。
And that's what really bothers me about it, that it's such a fucking secret as to who you're inviting, and then you show up, oh, you're here. Oh, oh, oh, hello, you know. Who needs that? Tell me who's going and I'll see if I wanna go. Why can't I know? I should have a chance to educate my decision
这正是我最反感的地方，他们邀请了谁竟然搞得像个天大的秘密，然后你一到现场，噢，你也在啊。噢，噢，噢，嗨，你知道的。谁需要这个？告诉我都有谁去，我再决定要不要去。为什么我不能知道？我应该有机会
about the way I'm gonna spend my night. Exactly, and all of a sudden, then you're spending two and a half hours. Right. With a stranger, you've got nothing to say to them. Right. Like, if you're not going to go to the beach, you're going to look at the weather, and if the weather's rainy, you're not going to fucking go for two and a half hours, right? Exactly.
为我怎么度过这个夜晚做出明智的决定。没错，结果突然之间，你就得花两个半小时。没错。和一个你无话可说的陌生人待在一起。没错。这就好比，如果你不打算去海滩，你会先看看天气，如果天气下雨，你他妈才不会去待上两个半小时，对吧？一点没错。
That's right. I don't get it. I don't get it. So, a couple of weeks ago, I was invited and I asked. I said, who's gonna be there? And offense was taken, okay? And I didn't go. Good, smart.
就是这样。我搞不懂。我实在搞不懂。所以，几个星期前，我收到了邀请，然后我问了。我说，都有谁会去？结果对方觉得被冒犯了，好吧？然后我就没去。好，明智。
Because you found it, because they told you? They told you? No, they didn't tell me. Oh, okay. Do you throw dinner parties? Me? Yeah. Have I ever said, let's have a dinner party?
因为你发现了，因为他们告诉你了？他们告诉你了吗？不，他们没告诉我。噢，好吧。你会办晚宴吗？我？对。我有没有说过，咱们办个晚宴吧？
Or let's say you have six, seven, eight people over. Would you then tell the other people who's coming? Yes. Yes. Exactly. Yeah. I'm golden ruling it. Yeah.
或者假设你邀请了六、七、八个人来家里。你会把其他要来的人告诉受邀者吗？会。会。没错。对。我会奉行黄金法则。对。
I'm not trying to trick people over to my house. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. I'm golden ruling it. I'm doing unto them as I want them to do unto me. I'm with you on that. I get kind of offended. These guys know, like, if you invite me
我可不是在设圈套把人骗到家里来。对，没错。对。我是在践行黄金法则。己所不欲，勿施于人。这点上我和你立场一致。我确实觉得有点被冒犯。这些家伙都知道，比如，如果你邀请我
to a one-year-old's birthday party, I'm fucking mad. I'm like, don't invite me to a one-year-old's birthday party. That's outrageous. I'll go one step further. Don't invite me to your wedding. You know, the wedding's a nightmare. Don't invite me to your wedding on a weekend in the summer?
去参加一个一岁小孩的生日派对，我会他妈的抓狂。我会觉得，别邀请我去一岁小孩的生日派对。这太离谱了。我再退一步。别邀请我去参加你的婚礼。你知道的，婚礼就是个噩梦。别邀请我在夏天的周末去参加你的婚礼？
A summer weekend? The bar mitzvah's even worse than the wedding. Worse. Those don't adjust. No, but my kids go to the bar mitzvah's because that's where all the makeouts happen. Yeah, just the service. Yeah, you just come to the service, not the party.
夏天的周末？成年礼甚至比婚礼还要糟糕。更糟。那些根本没法调整。不，但我的孩子们会去参加成年礼，因为那是所有卿卿我我发生的地方。对，只去仪式部分。对，你只去仪式，不去派对。
No, but anything to do with it, they're just intolerable, top to bottom. Yeah. Yeah. I cannot go. Oh, and you gotta bring a check. Yeah. We'll be right back.
不，但任何跟这相关的事，从头到尾都令人无法忍受。对。对。我简直去不了。噢，而且你还得随个红包。对。我们马上回来。
This episode of Smart List is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. So I eat Skinny Pop all the time. Scotty and I will have movie night. We'll pop open the Skinny Pop and we'll put it in a big fat bowl and we'll eat pretty much the whole thing because we can't stop eating it.
本期《聪明清单》节目部分内容由Skinny Pop爆米花为您呈现。我经常吃Skinny Pop。斯科蒂和我经常有电影之夜。我们会拆开Skinny Pop，倒进一个大碗里，然后基本上把一整碗都吃光，因为我们根本停不下来。
And that's our snack for the evening. I also use it sometimes as a substitute for potato chips. Like while I'm making a sandwich, instead of grabbing the chips, I'll grab the skinny pop. It's so good. Skinny pop is light and tasty. It is a deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil, and salt and every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more. In addition to their original popcorn, skinny pop offers a variety of delicious flavors ranging from cheddar jalapeno to sweet and salty kettle, which I love.
这就是我们的夜间零食。有时我也用它来代替薯片。比如我在做三明治时，与其去拿薯片，不如拿一把Skinny Pop。太好吃了。Skinny Pop轻盈美味。它是爆米花、油和盐的美味而简单的结合，每一口完美爆开的原味爆米花都让你回味无穷。除了原味爆米花，Skinny Pop还提供各种美味口味，从切达墨西哥胡椒到甜咸焦糖，我都爱不释手。
Shop Skinny Pop now. From Wondery, this is The Spy Who. This month, we open the file on Oleg Leleyn, the spy who saved MI5. Lenin's actions changed the course of the Cold War in the 1970s, a Russian who defected to Britain after being caught in a love affair that shook the world. His actions triggered the biggest removal of spies by any government in history. It's a story of an overstretched security service in need of a win and a covert plan to bring catastrophe to Britain's streets.
立即选购Skinny Pop。来自Wondery的节目《间谍是谁》。这个月，我们解密了奥列格·列利亚夫的档案，正是这个间谍拯救了军情五处。列利亚夫的行动改变了20世纪70年代冷战的进程，他是一个俄罗斯人，在一场震惊世界的桃色绯闻曝光后叛逃到英国。他的行动引发了历史上任何政府最大规模的间谍驱逐潮。这是一个关于捉襟见肘的安全机构迫切需要一场胜利，以及一个企图给英国街头带来灾难的秘密计划的故事。
Follow the Spy Who on the Wondery app or wherever you listen to podcasts or you can binge the full season of The Spy Who Saved MI5 early and ad-free with Wondery Plus. I'm Afua Hirsch. I'm Peter Frankopan. And in our podcast Legacy, we explore the lives of some of the biggest characters in history. This season, we delve into the life of Alan Turing. Why are we talking about Alan Turing, Peter?
在Wondery应用程序上收听《间谍是谁》，或在您收听播客的任何地方收听，或者您可以借助Wondery Plus提前且无广告地畅听拯救了军情五处的间谍这一整季。我是阿富阿·赫希。我是彼得·弗兰科潘。在我们的播客《传奇》中，我们探索历史伟大人物的生活。本季，我们将深入探讨阿兰·图灵的生活。彼得，我们为什么要谈论阿兰·图灵？
Alan Turing is the father of computer science and some of those questions we're thinking about today around artificial intelligence. Turing was so involved in setting and framing what some of those questions were, but he's also interesting for lots of other reasons, Afro. He had such a fascinating life. He was unapologetically gay at a time when that was completely criminalised and stigmatised. And from his imagination, he created ideas that have formed a very physical, practical foundation for all of the technology on which our lives depend. And on top of that, he's responsible for being part of a team that saved millions, maybe
阿兰·图灵是计算机科学之父，我们今天围绕人工智能思考的一些问题，也与他息息相关。图灵深度参与了其中一些问题的设定和框架搭建，但阿富阿，他因为许多其他原因同样引人入胜。他的人生如此传奇。在一个同性恋完全被定罪和污名化的时代，他毫不掩饰自己的同性恋身份。凭着他的想象力，他创造的理念为我们生活所依赖的所有技术奠定了非常实际、非常物质的基础。除此之外，他在二战期间利用数学和计算机科学进行密码破译的工作，使他成为拯救了数百万甚至可能是
even tens of millions of lives because of his work during the Second World War using maths and computer science to code break. So join us on Legacy, wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Matt Ford. And I'm Alice Levine. And we're the hosts of British Scandal. In our latest series, we're visiting one of the rockiest sibling relationships ever. Okay, so I'm thinking Danny and Kylie. No, no, no, I'm thinking Anne Boleyn and the other Boleyn.
数千万人生死存亡的团队成员之一。欢迎在各大播客平台收听《传奇》。我是马特·福特。我是爱丽丝·莱文。我们是英国丑闻的主持人。在我们的最新系列中，我们将探究史上最剑拔弩张的手足关系之一。好吧，我想到了丹妮和凯莉。不，不，不，我想到了安妮·博林和另一个博林。
No, no, Barry and Paul Chuckle. No, it's Noel and Liam Gallagher. Now these two couldn't be more different, but they're tied to each other in musical dependency. Despite their music catching the attention of people around the world, Liam's behaviour could destroy their chances. However, their manager saw an opportunity to build a brand around their rebellious nature.
不，不，巴里和保罗·查克。不，是诺尔和利亚姆·加拉格尔。这两个人性格迥异，但在音乐创作上却又互为依靠。尽管他们的音乐吸引了全世界人们的注意，但利亚姆的行为可能会毁掉他们的前途。然而，他们的经纪人看到了一个机会，决定围绕他们叛逆的个性打造一个品牌。
It's got fights on boats, fights on planes, fights on land. They just fight everywhere. If you like fights, you'll love this. To find out the full story, follow British Scandal wherever you listen to podcasts, or listen early and ad-free on Wondry+, on Apple Podcasts or on the Wondry app. All right, back to the show. So I wrote a bunch of like, quite, I want to do like a speed thing with you because I wrote what you hate that you're going to introduce a new format here. Just one word answer. You think Larry wants to do the speed? We've never done a new format here? Is this just one word answers?
里面有船上打架、飞机上打架、陆地上打架。他们到处打架。如果你喜欢看打架，你一定会爱上这个。想要了解完整的故事，请在各大播客平台关注《英国丑闻》，或者在Apple Podcasts或Wondery+应用上提前且无广告收听Wondry+的内容。好了，回到节目中。所以我写了一堆，呃，我想跟你玩个快问快答，因为我写了——你讨厌别人在这里引入新格式。只需一个字回答。你觉得拉里想玩快问快答吗？我们以前从没在这里搞过新格式！这难道只是单字回答吗？
You think Larry wants to do the speed? We've never done a speed. Why are you doing it for Larry? It's just a terrible idea. Terrible. Yeah, make Larry the monkey. Oh, Sean's upset. Okay, Sean, do one speed thing.
你觉得拉里想玩快问快答吗？我们从来没搞过快问快答。你凭什么替拉里做决定？这简直是个糟糕透顶的主意。太糟了。对，把拉里当猴耍。噢，肖恩不高兴了。好吧，肖恩，玩一个快问快答。
One... Go ahead. He's worked on it with Scotty all weekend. No. Let's hear it. No, no, no, this is gonna be fun. No, it's not gonna be horrible now. What about a stage story, Larry? What about when he went to Broadway? Oh, there you go. Let's do that. No, no, no, this is gonna be fun. No, it's not gonna be horrible now. What about a stage story, Larry?
一个……开始吧。他整个周末都跟斯科蒂在琢磨这个呢。不。我们听听看。不，不，不，这会很有趣的。不，现在不会变得很糟糕。来个舞台故事怎么样，拉里？聊聊他去百老汇的时候？噢，这就对了。我们聊聊那个。不，不，不，这会很有趣的。不，现在不会变得很糟糕。来个舞台故事怎么样，拉里？
What about when he went to Broadway? Oh, there you go, let's do that. How about that, Sean? Larry, I saw your show on Broadway, you didn't see mine. I loved it though. If I had been in New York when it was on, I definitely would have got it. For six months.
聊聊他去百老汇的时候？噢，对了，我们就聊那个。怎么样，肖恩？拉里，我看过你在百老汇的演出，你没看过我的。不过我很喜欢。如果我在纽约上演时也在的话，我绝对会去看。连演六个月。
For six months. I was gonna fly to New York? Yes, I flew to New York to see yours. Who asked you to? I didn to New York to see yours! Who asked you to? I didn't tell you to do that! I would have dissuaded you! I would have said,
连演六个月。我会为了去看飞去纽约？对，我飞去纽约看你的了！谁让你去的？我才没让你去！我会劝阻你的！我会说，
Are you nuts? I don't want you to come! That's what I would have told you! And you should have told me the same thing! Like a good friend, yep. Now tell me, I did see that show and you were fucking great in it. It's so nice of you to say that. Wait, which one was this?
你疯了吗？我才不想让你来！我当时就会这么告诉你！你当时也该这么劝我！像个好朋友一样，对吧。现在告诉我，我确实看过那场演出，你在里面棒极了。你这么说太好了。等等，这是哪一出？
Bring it back down. Which show? Something with fishes. It's fishes. I you to say that. Which one was this? Bring it back down. Which show? Something with fishes. It's fishes. I'm on the fish. It was called Fish in the Dark. Fish in the Dark. Fish in the Dark.
把话题拉回来。哪出戏？跟鱼有关的。就是《鱼》。我这么说太好了。等等，这是哪一出？把话题拉回来。哪出戏？跟鱼有关的。就是《鱼》。我演的就是那条鱼。那部戏叫《暗中之鱼》。《暗中之鱼》。《暗中之鱼》。
Yeah. But I thought it was great and you told me that you didn't love the experience of eight shows a week. No. Did you not know that that's what you were getting into? I'm not shocked by that. How'd that sneak up on you, Larry? Yeah. I don't know. It was the dumbest decision I've ever made in my life.
对。但我觉觉得挺棒的，而你跟我说，你其实并不喜欢一周演八场的经历。没有。你难道不知道自己要面对的是这个吗？我对此并不感到震惊。这怎么能打你个措手不及呢，拉里？对啊。我不知道。这是我这辈子做过最蠢的决定。
Have you spoken to that agent since? It was my fault. I'm the one who agreed to it. It was my fault. I didn't write it to be in it. Right. I got talked into it by the producer. Wow. Yeah. And you hated it. How long was that run?
你后来联系过那个经纪人吗？是我的错。我是那个点头答应的人。是我的错。我写剧本可不是为了自己去演的。没错。我是被制作人说服的。哇。是的。而你恨透了。那个剧目演了多久？
The first show was February 4th. The last show was June 9th in 2015. Wow. Wow. So 144 performances. How many months is that? What are you writing again? February, March, April, May. Yeah, it's five months. you do again? February, March, April, May. Yeah, it's five months.
第一场演出是2月4日。最后一场是2015年的6月9日。哇。哇。所以是144场演出。那是几个月？你又在算什么？二月，三月，四月，五月。对，是五个月。你再算一遍？二月，三月，四月，五月。四个半月。
You dig that? Sorry. February, March, April, May. Four and a half. Sean, how many did you do of Good Night Oscar? Six months. Oh no, I did five months in New York and three months, or two or three months in New York.
你弄明白了吗？抱歉。二月，三月，四月，五月。四个半月。肖恩，你的《晚安，奥斯卡》演了多少场？六个月。噢不，我在纽约演了五个月，还有三个月，或者两三个月在纽约。
But how many performances? He knows his number. He knows his number. You don't know? I don't know. How many shows did you do a week? Seven. Oh.
但演了多少场？他记得自己的数字。他记着自己的数字呢。你不知道？我不知道。你一周演几场？七场。噢。
Yeah. That's better than eight. I got a moment to rest for a second. One less. Yeah. But you had a heavy lift in that. You were driving the whole thing. Yeah.
对。那比八场强。我能稍微休息一会儿。少了一场。对。但你那部戏的体力消耗很大。全靠你一个人撑全场。对。
Yeah. And you hated it. Never again. It was boring. Doing the same stuff over night after night after night, I found it boring. Do you have any funny stories? Didn't you get hurt once? Did you lose your voice ever? No boring. Do you have any funny stories? Didn't you get hurt once? You lose your voice ever?
对。而你恨透了。再也不干了。太无聊了。日复一日、夜复一夜地重复演同样的内容，我觉得很无聊。你有什么有趣的故事吗？你没受过伤吗？你有没有过失声的时候？没有，无聊。你有什么有趣的故事吗？你没受过伤吗？你失过声吗？
No, I don't have any funny stories. Okay, good. Did you? I did notice that the- Great question though, Sean. Thanks. That it becomes so rote, and there's no creativity at all after you do the first 10.
没有，我没有什么有趣的故事。好吧，很好。你有没有？不过肖恩，这倒是个好问题。谢谢。演到后来变得极其公式化，演完前十场之后就完全没有任何创造力了。
Right, I understand. You're just doing the same thing over and over again. It's kind of fun though to find new things, to try new things that are so small that it makes the scene better. Okay, I tried something new once. Oh, I guess you do have a story. And I got so thrown by it, the whole system broke down and I forgot the next line.
对，我明白。你只是在机械地重复同样的事情。不过，尝试一些微小的变化，让场景变得更好，其实挺有意思的。好吧，我曾经尝试过一次新的改变。噢，我猜你确实有个故事。结果我被搞得方寸大乱，整个表演系统都崩溃了，我把下一句台词给忘光了。
Oh no. I looked a different way. Instead of looking to the right, I looked to the left and all of a sudden, it all went askew. How'd you get back on track? Did somebody whisper something from the wings? No, I realized where I was finally, but that was the last time I tried anything different. Yeah, I was doing a play and this guy was carrying a briefcase in one hand and right before we went out,
噢不。我看错了方向。我本来应该看右边，结果我看了左边，突然之间，一切都乱套了。你是怎么找回状态的？有人在侧幕条后面提醒你吗？没有，我最后终于反应过来自己演到哪了，但那是我最后一次尝试任何不同的演法。对，我以前演过一出戏，有个家伙手里拿著个公文包，就在我们上台之前，
we went out at the same time, he said, God, my hand hurts from carrying the briefcase the same way. I go, you should switch hands. He goes, oh. I go, but don't do it tonight. He goes, no, I'll do it. We walked out and he forgot every line.
我们同时上台，他说，天哪，我用同一个姿势拿公文包拿得手都酸了。我说，你应该换一只手拿。他说，哦。我说，不过今晚可别换。他说，不，我偏要换。结果我们一上台，他把所有台词都忘了。
Oh my God. Yeah, that's exactly the story. Exactly what I'm talking about. I got it, I understand. That's wild. Right, those neuro pathways are dug so deep based on. Larry, what do you do when you're not not doing your show anymore and you're not doing stand up?
噢天哪。对，这就是那个故事。完全就是我刚才说的那个意思。我懂了，我明白了。太疯狂了。没错，那些神经回路已经根据习惯根深蒂固了。拉里，当你不再出演自己的节目，也不再做单口喜剧时，你会做些什么？
What do you, I know you like to play golf, but is there anything else that you like to do that you have any sort of stupid hobbies or anything that you do to occupy your time that people wouldn't know? No, not really. No, nothing. Nothing, what do you watch TV?
你平时，我知道你喜欢打高尔夫球，但还有没有其他你喜欢做的事，比如有没有什么愚蠢的业余爱好，或者做点什么来打发时间是别人不知道的？没有，真的没有。没有，什么都没有。没有，你平时看电视吗？
What do you got cable news on? I do what everybody else does. I read, I watch TV. Yeah. What do you read? These guys don't read. No, I don't read. Do you read nonfiction or are you re-reading stuff
你是不是开着有线新闻？我和大家做的一样。我读书，我看电视。对。你读什么书？这几个家伙可都不读书。不，我不读书。你读的是非虚构类作品，还是在重读那些
about World Wars and things like that? Or you like romance novels? Romance novels? Yeah, you know, kind of fun. Do you read any spy novels? You get into that shit and anything like that? I read a great book about the spies in England. I forgot the name of it.
关于世界大战之类的书？还是你喜欢言情小说？言情小说？对，你知道的，挺有意思的。你读过什么间谍小说吗？你对那种玩意儿感兴趣吗？我读过一本关于英国间谍的好书。我忘了书名叫什么了。
Sorry, I apologize. I'm so sorry. We'll be cutting this, right? We'll cut that. I probably read it. So I love at the beginning of this interview, you were like, I kind of regret being here. And then on my next question, I read it. I probably read it. So, I love at the beginning of this interview, you were like, I kind of regret being here. And then my next question, and my next question was going to be, well, what else would you
对不起，我道歉。非常抱歉。我们会把这段剪掉的，对吧？我们会剪掉的。我大概读过。所以我喜欢的是，这次访谈刚开始时，你说，我有点后悔来这里。然后在接我的下一个问题时，我读过。我大概读过。所以，我喜欢的是，这次访谈刚开始时，你说，我有点后悔来这里。然后我的下一个问题，我接下来的问题本来是，好吧，那除此之外你还会
be doing? And apparently the answer is nothing. Reading a magazine. He'd rather be doing nothing than talking to us. I love that. I have a quick before we let you go there. I have this very quick, funny little thing that happened between me and you I'd love to get you to your speed round though No, it's too late. They were it was gonna be hysterical, but that's too bad
在干嘛？显然答案是：什么都没干。在看杂志。他宁愿无所事事，也不愿意跟我们聊天。我太喜欢这样了。在你挂断之前，我有个很短的想法。我和你之间发生过一件非常短小、有趣的事，我很想听听你的快问快答。不，已经太晚了。它们本来会……这本来会很爆笑的，但太遗憾了。
So listen the the I it's the I love you story outside of HBO I don't know if you remember this I asked you to do a show a long time ago That I was producing and you graciously declined because you're not afraid to say no. And then I didn't see you for like a year or something. And then I was at the HBO building and I was waiting for an elevator, an HBO building in Santa Monica, waiting for the elevator. When the door's open, you were there.
所以听着，这个……我在HBO之外听过一个“我爱你”的故事，我不知道你还记不记得。很久以前，我邀请你出演一个节目，那是我制作的，你非常客气地拒绝了，因为你很敢于说“不”。然后我有一年左右没见到你。接着我在HBO大楼里，我在等电梯，圣莫尼卡的HBO大楼，在等电梯。当门打开时，你就在那里。
And the first thing you said before I even said hello or anything, the door's open, you just go, I'm sorry. I just don't like those kinds you just go, I'm sorry. I just don't like those kinds of shows. I'm so sorry. They're just, they're not for me. I just, I'm so sorry. You're great, I just can't do it.
电梯门一开，我甚至还没来得及打招呼，你第一句话就直接说：“对不起。我只是不喜欢那种类型的……”你直接说：“对不起。我只是不喜欢那种类型的节目。真的很对不起。它们真的不适合我。我只是……真的很对不起。你很棒，我就是做不来。”
I go, I'm like, don't worry about it. I don't care. But I thought it was fascinating you hung onto that for over a year. And then when we were done chatting, I said, you know, you don't have to ever worry about anything like that, Larry, you know, it's no big deal. And don't worry about it.
我说，我当时想：别担心。我不在乎。但我当时觉得很着迷的是，这件事你居然记了一年多。然后当我们聊完后，我说：“你知道的，你根本不用为这种事担心，拉里，你知道的，这没什么大不了的。别担心。”
And you said, okay, and I said, I love you. And then you said, yeah, I don't do that. I don't do that, I'm not gonna say that. And then I laughed and you walked away and like two minutes later we said goodbye. And way in the distance you were getting your car and I'm still at the elevator and you walked away and like two minutes later we say goodbye and way in the distance You were getting your car and I'm still at the elevator and you go You old soft that was real sweet, yeah, don't let's cut that soon
然后你说：“好吧。”我说：“我爱你。”然后你说：“行吧，我不干那事。我不干那事，我才不说那句话呢。”然后我笑了，你走开了。大约两分钟后，我们道别了，你在很远的地方正准备上车，而我还在电梯那儿。你走开了大约两分钟后，我们道别了，你在很远的地方正准备上车，而我还在电梯那儿，然后你喊道：“你个老软心肠的……”这真的很温馨，别……咱们等下把这段剪掉吧。
Okay, sweet Larry. Sweet Larry. We don't want that out in the public. No. We're gonna let you go. Real quick speed round, Sean. I was gonna add... Fucking go! Oh, it's on a computer? Did you AI this?
好吧，温柔的拉里。温柔的拉里。我们不想让这个公开。对。我们要让你挂电话了。快问快答环节，肖恩。我本来要加……他妈的快开始！哦，是在电脑上吗？你用人工智能生成的？
I wrote him down last night. What is it? This is like a Rorschach thing? I don't know who that is. Would you rather be subjected to someone showing you pictures of their kids for an entire afternoon or lose a foot? Do you ever pick up a dinner? No, that's not, that's a,
我昨晚写下来的。这是什么？这就像罗夏墨迹测试吗？我不知道那是谁。你宁愿一整个下午都被强迫看别人给你看他们孩子的照片，还是失去一只脚？你吃过晚餐吗？不，这不是，这是一个……
do you ever watch Shark Tank, by the way? That's a good question. Yeah, it's a very good question. But of course I need the foot, so. You need the foot. Right. I could play golf without the foot. Oh, would you rather wear only uncomfortable shoes
顺便问一下，你看过《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）吗？这是个好问题。对，这是个非常好的问题。但当然我需要这只脚，所以……你需要这只脚。没错。没有这只脚我也能打高尔夫。哦，你宁愿每次出门
whenever you go outside or comfortable shoes 24 hours a day and can never take them off? You can never take the shoes off? You mean even when you're sleeping? Yeah, showering, swimming, things like that. Now listen, what about this one? Would you rather live without the internet or live without air conditioning and heating?
都只能穿不舒服的鞋子，还是24小时都穿着舒服的鞋子而且永远不能脱下来？鞋子永远不能脱？你的意思是连睡觉的时候都不能脱？对，洗澡、游泳之类的时候也是。现在听着，那这个呢？你宁愿没有互联网生活，还是没有空调和暖气生活？
Easily, that's such an easy question. What do you think? I'd rather live without the internet or live without air conditioning and heating? Easily, that's such an easy question. What do you think? I'd rather live without the air conditioning and heating. I'd rather live without the internet, even without the air conditioning. I hate the internet. What's something that you just recently realized that you were embarrassed you didn't realize earlier?
太简单了，这问题太简单了。你觉得呢？我宁愿没有互联网生活，还是没有空调和暖气生活？太简单了，这问题太简单了。你觉得呢？我宁愿没有空调和暖气。我宁愿没有互联网，哪怕没有空调也行。我讨厌互联网。最近有什么事是你刚刚才意识到，并且为自己之前没有意识到而感到尴尬的？
What's that? It's bad. What would the world be like if it was filled with male and female copies of you? That's the last one. I. What would the world be like if it was filled with male and female copies of you? That's the last one. I think it would be a much better place. Wow. There you go. That's the only one we're keeping. Good answer. Larry David, you're the sweetest. I had the best time with you on your show. Thank you for being on this show. And uh, sure be your enthusiasm. The final, is it called the final frontier? What's the name? Is there
什么事？太糟了。如果世界上全都是男性和女性版本的你，世界会变成什么样？这是最后一个问题。我。如果世界上全都是男性和女性版本的你，世界会变成什么样？这是最后一个问题。我觉得那会是个好得多地方。哇。这就对了。这是我们唯一保留的问题。回答得好。拉里·大卫，你太贴心了。我在你的节目里度过了一段最美好的时光。谢谢你来参加这个节目。还有……一定得看你的《抑制热情》。最后，那个叫什么来着？最终边疆？叫什么名字？有没有
like a subtitle? No, it's just a crew. I don't think so. I think it's called That's Enough. That's Enough. That's Enough. Yeah. I like that, yeah. That would be a nice Larry David,
像副标题之类的？不，只有一个摄制组。我不这么认为。我觉得它叫《够了》（That's Enough）。《够了》。《够了》。对。我喜欢这个，对。那会是个挺好的拉里·大卫……
yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's very good. Yeah. I'm looking, Sean, I'm really looking forward to people seeing you on Curb, because you're fantastic in it. Well, thank you, thank you for having me're fantastic in it. Well, thank you. Thank you for having me.
对，对，对。对，那非常好。对。肖恩，我很期待大家看到你在《抑制热情》里的表现，因为你在里面棒极了。噢，谢谢，谢谢你们邀请我……因为你在里面棒极了。噢，谢谢。谢谢你们邀请我。
I loved it. It was so fun. Boy, we had some good laughs. Will and I are happy to be involved in any of the reshoots. Or promotion. Or promotion. Or additional photography. We'll just do promo for the.
我太喜欢了。太有趣了。天哪，我们笑得太开心了。威尔和我很高兴能参与任何补拍工作。或者宣传。或者宣传。或者补拍镜头。我们只管做宣传……
We'll just do the junket. Yeah. Hey guys, this wasn't as awful as I thought it was gonna be. Hey, thanks man. That's one of the best reviews we've ever had. Did you have more fun here or on Morning Joe? I was so excited when I saw you on my favorite show, thanks man. That's one of the best reviews we've ever had. Did you have more fun here or on Morning Joe? I was so excited when I saw you on my favorite show, Morning Joe.
我们只管做宣传巡回。对。嘿，伙计们，这其实没我想象的那么糟糕。嘿，谢谢老兄。这是我们收到的最好的评价之一。你在我们这儿玩得更开心，还是在《早安乔》（Morning Joe）？当我看到你出现在我最喜欢的节目时，我太兴奋了……谢谢老兄。这是我们收到的最好的评价之一。你在我们这儿玩得更开心，还是在《早安乔》？当我看到你出现在我最喜欢的节目——《早安乔》里时，我太兴奋了。
Was that, was it great? I was so jealous you were on that set. Yeah, they're great. I want to go over there and say hi to those guys. Do you still golf, Larry? Oh yeah. You do? Not today. It's rainy. Too wet today. Do you see these guys there ever?
那是……太棒了吗？我太嫉妒你能去那个片场了。对，他们超棒的。我想过去跟那些家伙打个招呼。拉里，你现在还打高尔夫吗？哦，打啊。是吗？今天不打。下雨了。今天太湿了。你在那儿见过这些家伙吗？
We've played. I do. I see them out there. Yeah. We've never played. You guys are... We're going to play together one day. I'm off until October. I'm around. I played over at your club the other day for that, for the pro-am they did.
我们一起打过。我会的。我在那儿见过他们。对。我们从没一起打过。你们……我们总有一天会一起打的。我十月份之前都没空。我都在附近。前几天我为了他们举办的那个职业业余配对赛，去你们俱乐部打过球。
Yeah. I don't even get invited to that. Well, we'll just go ahead and won it. Come on. You won it. You won the pro-am on Wednesday. What? Yeah.
对。我甚至都没被邀请去。好吧，我们直接去把它赢下来吧。得了吧。你赢了。你赢了周三的职业业余配对赛。什么？对。
You had three birdies. My team did. Yeah, I did have three birdies. Who did you play with? I played with Sebastian Menescalco, and who else did I play with? And with Jeff Azov. And... Who was your pro? With Sam Burns. Wow, really?
你抓了三个小鸟球。我的团队抓的。对，我确实抓了三个小鸟球。你跟谁一起打的？我和塞巴斯蒂安·曼尼斯科尔科（Sebastian Maniscalco）一起打的，还有谁来着？还有杰夫·阿佐夫（Jeff Azov）。还有……你的职业球员搭档是谁？萨姆·伯恩斯（Sam Burns）。哇，真的吗？
Yeah, and he was great. Sam Burns went low that day, and Jeff Azov is great, as you know. He plays at your club, he's terrific. He's a club champ and then uh Sebastian um forget about it and then um I mean just to put it in terms that he would understand. Don't you find it curious that I'm not invited to play in that Pro Am? I find it very curious. How are you not invited to play at the Pro Am? It's your own club and you're a huge star. And then I'm there. Fucking ding-dong. Canadian asshole.
对，他太棒了。萨姆·伯恩斯那天打出了好成绩，而且如你所知，杰夫·阿佐夫也很棒。他在你们俱乐部打球，他超级棒。他是俱乐部冠军，然后呢……塞巴斯蒂安……忘了吧，然后呢……我是说，用他能听懂的话来表达：你不觉得奇怪吗？我居然没有被邀请去打那个职业业余配对赛？我觉得非常奇怪。你怎么会没有被邀请去打职业业余配对赛？那是你自己的俱乐部，而且你是个超级巨星。然后我在那儿。他妈的笨蛋。加拿大混蛋。
Canadian moron gets invited. How are you not? They're trying to go international. Anyway, well, Larry, we'll get out and play some day. That'd be good. And I'll show you around your own club and where to hit it and stuff. What's your index? I'm a 10.8.
加拿大傻瓜都被邀请了。你怎么会没有？他们正试图走向国际化。不管怎样，好吧，拉里，我们总有一天会出去打球的。那挺好的。我会带你参观你自己的俱乐部，告诉你球该往哪儿打之类的。你的差点是多少？我是个10.8。
Oh, you're not terrible. You're much better than I am. No, you're right around there, Larry. No, no, I'm not. This Bateman character, he's got a little bit of a swing. You know, he shot a 70 at Bel Air two weeks ago. Wow. Can you believe that? It scared the shit out of me. Wow. 70.
哦，你不算太差。你比我厉害多了。不，你就在那个水平左右，拉里。不，不，我不是。这个叫贝特曼（Bateman）的家伙，他挥杆有点两下子。你知道的，他两周前在贝莱尔（Bel Air）打出了70杆。哇。你敢相信吗？吓死我了。哇。70杆。
Wow. That was the last round I played and I won't play again until October. Or I'll probably shoot Oh, yeah, I'll shoot a hundred and five just working. You know, I'm still out here humping, you know trying to dance as fast as I can He's going to New York to work. He's back here this week. But what are you? What are you doing in New York? I'm doing some crime drama thingamabob. That's why I'm growing out all this crap Nonsense, what are you playing a cop or I'm playing a loser right crap beard and hair and all this nonsense. What are you playing? A cop or...?
哇。那是打完的最后一轮，我直到十月份都不会再打了。或者我可能会打出……哦，对，我只要随便一打就能打出105杆。你知道的，我依然在努力挣扎，你知道的，像飞蛾扑火一样拼命活着。他要回纽约去工作。这周他会回来。但你呢？你在纽约干嘛？我在拍某种犯罪题材的电视剧之类的小玩意儿。这就是为什么我留了所有这些烂……胡说八道，你演的是个警察还是……我演的是个失败者，对，留着垃圾一样的胡子和头发，还有所有这些胡说八道。你演的是个警察还是……？
I'm playing a loser, right? Look, how am I doing? Yeah, wow. You didn't need to grow out the hair and the beard for that, dude. Hey! Larry, I miss you. I'd love to have at least some food with you soon. Please say hi to Ashley. You're very nice to be doing this today with us. That was very kind of you. Very, very cool.
我演的是个失败者，对吧？你看，我演得怎么样？对，哇。老兄，你其实没必要为了那个去留长发和大胡子的。嘿！拉里，我想你了。我很希望能尽快和你一起吃顿饭。请代我向阿什利问好。今天你能抽空跟我们一起做这个节目，真的太好了。你太友好了。非常非常酷。
I don't know what to say to that. We're big fans. It should be, and I know you hate it, and not to embarrass you, you've done so much great stuff in your career, and for guys like me, and I can speak for these guys, it's a thrill. Honestly, you're such a funny guy,
我不知道该对这个说什么了。我们都是你的超级粉丝。这应该……而且我知道你讨厌这样，也不是为了让你尴尬，你在职业生涯中做出了那么多伟大的成就，对于像我这样的人——我可以代表这些伙计们说话——这真的太让人激动了。老实说，你是个这么有趣的人，
you're such a funny writer, such a funny performer, and it's inspiring to be totally, again, not to be on the spot, you don't have to respond, but it's great, and we look up to people like, you know, to you and what you do, I think it's awesome. What you do is not easy. One of my faves, yeah. You make it look very easy, and people need to know that it is not easy. 100%.
你是个这么有趣的编剧，这么有趣的表演者，这真的很鼓舞人心……再次强调，不是为了让你当众出丑，你不需要回应，但这真的很棒，我们很仰慕像你这样的人，仰慕你和你的成就，我觉得这太棒了。你做的事可一点也不容易。我最喜欢的之一，对。你把它表现得非常轻松，大家需要知道这其实一点也不容易。百分之百。
They'll say, oh, he's playing himself. Guess what, guys? Not simple, incredibly talented. Thank you. And I know it's not, and sometimes it's not cool in comedy to pay those kinds of compliments or whatever, but it is true and you are definitely an inspiration. So thank you for all the awesome stuff you've done. You're very, very nice to say that.
他们会说，哦，他只是在演他自己。猜猜怎么着，伙计们？这可不简单，非常有天赋。谢谢。而且我知道这不容易，有时候在喜剧界说这种恭维的话可能不太酷什么的，但这是真的，你绝对是一个灵感之源。所以谢谢你做过的所有那些了不起的事。你能这么说真是太好了、太好了。
I wish I could take it in. I know, you don't have to. You'll think about it again right when you're going to bed tonight. A little grin. A little thought bubble. Alright guys, see you. Thank you. Larry, love you. I love you.
真希望我能把这些夸奖全盘接受。我懂，你不用这样的。今晚你上床睡觉的那一刻，你又会想起这些话。露出一丝微笑。脑海里冒出一个小气泡。好吧，伙计们，再见。谢谢。拉里，爱你。我爱你。
There it is, you got it. He's great. I think I really do love that man. I just love being around him. Yeah, his deepest, darkest secret is that he's a sweetheart. I know. Such a sweetheart, yeah. I met his wife, Jay, you know his wife, Ashley?
就是这样，你懂的。他太棒了。我觉得我真的很爱那个人。我就是喜欢跟他在一起。对，他内心深处最黑暗的秘密其实是个大暖男。我懂。真的是个暖男，对。我见过他的妻子，杰伊，你知道他的妻子阿什利吗？
Tiny bit, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I met her once, she's so sweet. Oh, I met her one time. Yeah, they're a lot of fun. I like them a lot. Yeah, he's so, like Will, you know, like Will was saying, it's like he's one of the greats, you know?
略知一二，对。对，对。对，我见过她一次，她人太好了。哦，我见过她一次。对，他们很有趣。我非常喜欢他们。对，他就是那种……就像威尔，你知道的，正如威尔刚才所说，他就好像是那些最伟大的人物之一，你知道吗？
And that show's been on for 20, what did he say, four years, 20-some years? I really, honestly, genuinely would love to be on a set with him. That would be really, really rewarding. So fun. But, he said, I missed my chance. I gotta cast him in something.
而且那个节目已经播了20……他刚才说什么来着，四年，二十多年了？我真的、老实说、发自内心地很想跟他一起拍部戏。那真的会非常有成就感、非常棒。太有趣了。但是，他说，我错过了机会。我得在什么剧里安排他演个角色。
He'll do other stuff, He'll do other stuff. He'll do other stuff. Maybe this was it. Maybe this was us working together. This was the beginning and the end of it. He legit did say that, how come you're never on? And I was like, what's your show? You never asked me, so.
他会拍别的剧的，他会拍别的剧的。他会拍别的剧的。也许这就是了。也许这就是我们一起合作。这就是合作的开始和结束。他确实说过那样的话，怎么你从来没上过节目？然后我就说，你的节目是怎样的？你从来没邀请过我，所以……
Yeah. Do you ever say that when somebody comes up to you and asks to be on Smart List and you say, yeah, why haven't we had you on yet? And meanwhile you're thinking, you're not gonna have him on? Yeah. Yeah, see, it happens. I guess. It's tough.
对。每当有人走过来请求上《聪明豆》（SmartLess）节目时，你会不会也这么说：“对啊，为什么我们到现在还没邀请你上节目呢？”而与此同时你心里想的是：你根本不会邀请他上节目？对。对，你看，这事儿就是会发生。我想是的。这很难。
I know, it's tough to hear the truth, I guess. But he has his legacy, or like, he can always say he has one of the greatest shows in the history of American television. Two, two of the greatest shows. The Seinfeld show, and now this one. And he's only done two. And he's only done two.
我懂，听到真相可能挺难接受的。但他有他的传奇成就，或者说，他随时可以说他拥有美国电视史上最伟大的节目之一。两个，两个最伟大的节目。情景喜剧《宋飞正传》（Seinfeld），现在又有了这部。而且他总共就制作了两个。而且他总共就制作了两个。
Well, except for the Godfrey failed pilot. But we won't talk about that. You just brought it up. Well, but he's not even two for three. Because it was just a pilot never aired. So he's at 60% now. Now he's at 66%. He was, I guess, second ago, he was batting 1,000.
好吧，除了吉尔伯特·戈特弗里德（Gilbert Gottfried）那个没成功的试播集。但我们就不谈那个了。你刚把它提出来了。好吧，但他甚至都做不到三战两胜。因为那只是个从未播出的试播集。所以他现在成功率是60%。现在他的成功率是66%。我猜就在刚才，他的胜率还是百分之百。
And now he's still all the fame. Only been on two television shows and they're both probably in the top 10 ever in the history of television. All three, all three. The Gilbert Godfrey thing. Yeah. Yeah.
而现在他依然享有盛誉。只做过两档电视节目，而且这两档节目可能都跻身电视历史前十名。三个，三个。吉尔伯特·戈特弗里德那个东西。对。对。
Anyway. I know, he is so incredible. He's so fucking incredible. And I do mean it, apart from that, not only did he write himself license to do what he wants, right? In terms of his behavior and being as cranky as he wants in a way that is really, you know, invokes a lot of jealousy in me.
不管怎样。我懂，他太不可思议了。他他妈的太不可思议了。我是认真的，抛开这些不谈，不仅他为自己争取到了想做什么就做什么的特权，对吧？在行为举止方面，想发多大脾气就发多大脾气，这种特权……你知道的，真的引发了我内心的很多嫉妒。
But also he got paid really handsomely to do that. I don't think so. I think the story is that he deferred all the money because he just did it for the art. He never cashed those checks. Did not get a dollar from Seinfeld. No kidding. Yeah, he just loved it.
而且他拍这个还拿到了非常丰厚的报酬。我不这么认为。传闻说他把所有的钱都推迟领取了，因为他纯粹是为艺术献身。他从来没兑现过那些支票。从《宋飞正传》里没拿过一美元。开玩笑吧？对，他就是热爱。
Just love being there. No kidding. Yeah, we should call him back. Yeah, I just loved it. You know, seriously, somebody told me that and they promised me that they are aware of this information and they can prove it because they have an alibi. Bye! Bye!
就是喜欢身处其中。不是开玩笑吧？对，我们应该给他回个电话。对，我就是喜欢。你知道的，说真的，有人这么告诉我，他们向我保证他们知道这个内幕，而且他们能证明，因为他们有不在场证明。再见！再见！
Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye!
再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！
Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarff. Smart. Less.
再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！SmartLess。《SmartLess》由班尼特·巴巴里科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗伯·阿尔姆贾夫（Rob Armjarff）100%有机手工精制而成。SmartLess。
Guys, Jason had to scoot very quickly and apologize profusely for not being here for this little thing that we're about to do, which we're really excited about. He's missing the party. He's missing the fun. He's missing the party. Yes. He does feel really, really bad. Yeah.
伙计们，杰森必须得赶紧溜了，他为不能留下来参加我们接下来要做的这个小活动而深表歉意，我们对这个活动真的非常兴奋。他错过派对啦。他错过乐子啦。他错过派对啦。是的。他确实感到非常非常抱歉。对。
But we have a couple guests with us today for a super quick plug for a new Smartless media show called Pretty Sure I Can Fly. We can't wait for the show. We're super pumped. One of the hosts is a friend of the podcast, has been on before and actor filmmakers made us laugh for literally years. And his partner in crime is a woman
不过我们今天请来了几位嘉宾，为一档名为《我敢说我能飞》（Pretty Sure I Can Fly）的全新 Smartless 媒体节目做个超快速的宣传。我们等不及想看这个节目了。我们超级兴奋。其中一位主持人是本播客的老朋友，以前来过，他是一位演员兼电影制作人，字面意思上让我们笑了好多年。而他的搭档是一位女士
who we haven't had the pleasure of meeting yet. And sorry, and figuratively years. And figuratively years. You said literally years. And figuratively years. But literally years. At least me. And a woman who we haven't had the pleasure of meeting yet
我们还没来得及荣幸见到她。抱歉，是象征意义上的好多年。是象征意义上的好多年。你刚才说的是字面意思上的好多年。是象征意义上的好多年。但确实是字面意思上的。至少对我来说是这样。还有一位女士，我们还没来得及荣幸见到她，
who will be a friend of the show after this little chat and giggle. She's a brilliant writer and producer of one of the all time greats This American Life. Love that show. Willie, let's say hello to Johnny Knoxville and Elna Baker. Okay, I'm gonna say hello.
聊过天、开过玩笑之后，她就会成为本节目的好朋友了。她是《美国生活》（This American Life）这个史上最伟大节目之一的才华横溢的编剧和制作人。我太喜欢那个节目了。威利，让我们跟强尼·诺克斯维尔（Johnny Knoxville）和埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）打个招呼吧。好的，我来打招呼。
Hello. Well, hello. Hi guys. This is so exciting that you're here. Tell us about the show. I can't wait. I mean, I know about it, but tell everybody else about it.
你好。哦，你好。嗨，大家好。你们能来真是太让人兴奋了。给我们讲讲这个节目吧。我等不及了。我的意思是，我其实知道一些，但请向大家介绍一下吧。
Yeah. It's a show about people with more balls than a bowling alley. As people who've achieved great things while thumbing their nose at naysayers, established thought, failure, personal safety, and gravity. Yeah, I love that. I love the press release that says, for people who have done things that have never been done
好的。这是一个关于那些胆量比保龄球馆的球还要多的人的节目。他们是那些在对反对者、既定思维、失败、人身安全和重力不屑一顾的同时，取得了伟大成就的人。是的，我喜欢这个。我喜欢那个新闻稿上的说法，上面写着：“致那些做出了在有人去做之前从未被做过的事情的人。”
until someone did them. Yeah, that's pretty good writing, huh? Yeah, it's pretty good. And I will say, Knoxville, you've got some history with this. You've obviously spent some time in between, over the years doing shit that other people won't do, stuff that seems really scary and gnarly.
是的，写得挺好，对吧？对，挺不错的。而且我得说，诺克斯维尔，你在这方面确实有点历史。这些年来，你显然花了一些时间去做别人不敢做的事，那些看起来非常吓人、非常硬核的事。
Yeah. So I can see it, but Elna, how much of an appetite do you have for doing shit that you didn't think people could do? I mean, to an extent, I mean, I grew up Mormon, so I wasn't allowed to do anything. And so, like, for me, I guess, it wasn't like being brave in terms of like jumping off a cliff, but it was like leaving a religion, giving hand jobs. Like, there were, you know, there were the things
对。所以我能理解，但埃尔娜，你对于去做那些你原本以为人们做不到的事，有多大的胃口？我的意思是，在某种程度上，我的意思是，我是摩门教长大的，所以我什么都不被允许做。所以，对不像我来说，我觉得，这倒不是说像从悬崖上跳下去那种勇敢，而是像离开一个宗教、帮人打飞机。你看，有这些事情，
that I had to figure out. That was the first thing. Wow. And that's why I joined. Well, that's what led you to leave, ultimately, one of the things, right? You were 28? Yes, I left at 20.
是我不得不去摸索的。那是第一件事。哇。这就是我加入的原因。好吧，这最终导致你离开，是原因之一，对吧？你当时28岁？对，我28岁离开的。
I had, I touched a penis for the first time at 28. Is that true? 28. That is true, yeah. It was touching the penis, the thing that opened the... Yes, it was. That was the gateway, penis was the gateway drug? The penis was the gateway, yeah. When did you have your first coke?
我28岁时第一次摸了阴茎。真的吗？28岁。那是真的，是的。摸阴茎是那件打开了……是的，就是它。那是敲门砖，阴茎是敲门砖毒品？阴茎是敲门砖，是的。你什么时候喝的第一口可乐？
Coca-Cola like Coca-Cola Otherwise she's gonna say 8 a.m I was like a we were kind of Mormons who drank Coca-Cola But I didn't have my first coffee until I was 28 and I remember like being so afraid to order it just cuz I did So everything happened at 28 everything cuz I left at 28. Yeah, once I it, just because I didn't know how to say the word. Wait, so everything happened at 28? Everything, because I left at 28. Yeah, once I touched a dick, I was, you know. Yeah, tell me about it.
可口可乐，就像可口可乐，否则她会说是早上8点。我就像个……我们是那种喝可口可乐的摩门教徒。但我直到28岁才喝了第一杯咖啡，我记得当时点咖啡时害怕极了，就是因为我……所以一切都发生在28岁，一切，因为我28岁离开的。是的，一旦我……，就是因为我不知道怎么发那个词的音。等等，所以一切都发生在28岁？一切，因为我28岁离开的。是的，一旦我摸了老二，我就……你知道的。是啊，跟我说说。
Same. Sean. Yeah, tell me about it. Catholicism, same thing. So wait, did you, do you still have family members in the church? Everyone, yeah, everyone is still moving. You have a good relationship?
一样。肖恩。是啊，跟我说说。天主教，也是一样的。等等，你，你现在还有家人在教会里吗？所有人，是的，所有人还在里面。你们关系好吗？
Decent, yeah, great, yeah. Johnny, what about you? Well, I started with decent. I mean, I'd love to dig into that a little bit. You open with decent, I'm gonna take you word of. I realize they might hear this. One little relationship. By the way, if they're listening to this,
还可以，是的，很好，是的。强尼，你呢？嗯，我一开始是从“还可以”说起的。我的意思是，我很想深入了解一下。你以“还可以”开头，我要相信你的话。我意识到他们可能会听到这个。一个小小的关系。顺便说一句，如果他们正在听这个，
then they're lapsed, and then they're just as guilty as you are, and now the playing field is level. Yeah, but Johnny, what denomination did you grow up in? Catholicism? Oh, Southern Baptist. It was intense. Oh, that's right, I knew that. Yeah. That's right.
那他们就已经背离了，那他们跟你一样有罪，现在大家扯平了。对，但强尼，你是在什么教派长大？天主教？哦，美南浸信会。那可太强烈了。哦，对哦，我知道这个。是的。没。
Was it hardcore? Well, I didn't realize it was pretty, how intense it was at the time. But, you know, it's not like the Pentecostals who handle snakes, but you know, Southern Baptist, you're not supposed to dance or, you know. But my parents didn't believe in... They weren't that strict, so... But if you... If you handle the Pentecostals, they could maybe be on an episode of Pretty Sure I Can Fly,
那是极端的吗？嗯，我当时并没有意识到它是挺……当时有多强烈。但是，你知道，这不像那些玩蛇的五旬节派，但你知道，美南浸信会，你是不准跳舞的，或者说……但我的父母不相信……他们没那么严格，所以……但如果你……如果你去玩蛇五旬节派，他们或许能上《我敢说我能飞》的一集，
because if they're handling snakes... Oh, yeah. There you go. That's what I'm saying. I'm saying being so repressed makes you want to go take these risks later on in life. Oh, totally. I mean, that's one of the things that, yeah, that's what I'm saying. I'm saying being so repressed makes you want to go take these risks later on in life Oh, totally. I mean, that's one of the things that like I love about interviewing the different people we've interviewed is like I Remember this sports writer telling me that like all the greatest athletes had some primal wound That and that thing that happened in their childhood is what makes them like achieve or even try For sure and so many of these people that we've talked to
因为如果他们玩蛇的话……哦，对。就是这样。我想说的是，受到如此压抑会让你想在日后的人生中去承担这些风险。哦，完全是。我的意思是，那是其中一件事，是的，这就是我想说的。我想说的是，受到如此压抑会让你想在日后的人生中去承担这些风险。哦，完全是。我的意思是，那也是其中一件事，就像我喜欢采访我们采访过的不同人的地方一样，我记得有个体育记者告诉我，所有最伟大的运动员都有某种原始的创伤，而他们童年发生的这件事，正是让他们能够取得成就甚至去尝试的原因。肯定的，我们聊过的这么多人里，
like you find out oh like you know Manny Pigg who you know you've seen on Jackass and who Johnny knows like I had no idea that like his father was killed by a firing squad in Cuba Like the origins of what made him crazy do these insane brave things? of what made him do these insane, brave things came from something really deep and real, or like Garrett McNamara, who's the 100-foot wave guy. He learned about his child. It's bonkers.
你会发现，哦，比如曼尼·皮格（Manny Puig），你曾在《蠢蛋搞怪秀》（Jackass）里见过他，强尼也认识他，我根本不知道他的父亲在古巴被行刑队处决了。他之所以变得疯狂、做出这些疯狂勇敢行为的起源，来自于某种非常深沉和真实的东西，或者像加勒特·麦克纳马拉（Garrett McNamara），也就是那个创下100英尺巨浪纪录的人。他了解到了他的童年。这太荒谬了。
He basically, at one point, his mother was this hippie, but she put him in this cult. A lot of cults. A lot of cults, but the most memorable. He was in many cults? Many cults, but the sort of the most memorable. He was in many cults? Many cults, but the one they had to renounce all their possessions, he and his brother had to wear bed sheets. They just walked around, they had to beg for everything, they couldn't buy anything.
他基本上，有一段时间，他母亲是个嬉皮士，但她把他送进了一个邪教。很多邪教。很多邪教，但最让人难忘的。他在很多邪教里？很多邪教，但某种程度上最让人难忘的。他在很多邪教里？很多邪教，但他们必须放弃所有财产的那一个，他和他的哥哥必须穿床单。他们就这样四处走动，不得不乞讨所有东西，他们什么也不能买。
And it was just so humiliating to be walking the streets in Berkeley in these outfits begging for things. And these back stories are like what get them to do these things. Yeah, it's incredible. Johnny, have any of these stories inspired you to try something? Well, I'm a little slow on the uptake.
在伯克利街头穿着这些行头乞讨东西，实在是太屈辱了。而这些背景故事正是促使他们去做这些事情的原因。是的，这太不可思议了。强尼，这些故事里有没有哪一个启发你尝试过什么？嗯，我这人脑子转得有点慢。
So I'm trying to not do things anymore. I'm trying to overcome my, anymore. I'm trying to overcome my You know Addiction to yourself dangerous Dangerous situations it did become an addiction. It must it must what is that? Was there a thing like was there like a common? Trait that you noticed in a lot of these people that you, other than the childhood, a lot of them came from difficult childhoods. Anything else that gave them that fearlessness? I think the, yeah, if there's a through line, people on the show, it's bravery and being colorful.
所以我现在正努力不再去做那些事。我正试图克服我的，不再。我正试图克服我的，你知道的，对危险、危险状况的成瘾，这确实成了一种瘾。一定是的，一定是的，那是什么？有没有一件事，比如有没有一个共同的特征，你注意到这些很多人都有的，除了童年，他们很多人都有艰难的童年。还有什么赋予了他们这种无畏精神？我认为，是的，如果说节目中的人有什么共同点的话，那就是勇敢和丰富多彩。
And these people are extremely determined. Very determined. Wow. And determined. Yeah, wow. And usually, I mean, like, it's complicated though, right? Because, like, you're talking about, like, adrenaline junkies, right? Right, right, right. Some are. Some, like, get in and then kind of become addicted, and then they're trying to accomplish something great,
这些人极其坚定。非常坚定。哇。而且很坚定。是的，哇。而且通常，我的意思是，这很复杂，对吧？因为，比如，你在谈论，比如肾上腺素瘾君子，对吧？对，对，对。有些是。有些人，比如加入了，然后就上瘾了，然后他们试图完成某项伟大的成就，
but they're also, like, putting their... I mean, you're a perfect example, Johnny. Like, you... Put your life on the... Yeah, you kept putting your life on the line, But they're also like putting their I mean you're a perfect example Johnny like you Put your life on the yeah, you can putting your life on the line and then ultimately like suffered a traumatic brain injury So like there's this level at which like you're on the razor's edge of like admiring and also being like you guys should stop Sean wants to know and just ask you that I want to bear he doesn't want to bear himself. Can you get a traumatic brain injury from watching TV every night? You can but But look at me. I'm still here. Hey Sean Have you seen hundred foot wave by the way? No, you have to watch this so the good thing and it's by that guy
但他们同时也，比如，把他们的……我的意思是，你就是一个完美的例子，强尼。比如，你……把你的生命置于……是的，你不断地把你的生命置于危险之中，但他们同时也，比如，把他们的……我的意思是，你就是一个完美的例子，强尼。比如，你……把你的生命置于……是的，你不断地把你的生命置于危险之中，并最终，比如，遭受了创伤性脑损伤。所以，在某种程度上，你游走在刀刃边缘：既钦佩他们，又会觉得“你们应该停下来”。肖恩想知道并直接问你这个，我想承担，他不想承担。你每天晚上看电视能得创伤性脑损伤吗？可以，但看看我。我还在呢。嘿，肖恩，顺便问一下，你看过《百尺巨浪》（100 Foot Wave）吗？没有，你必须看这个，所以好的一点是，它是由那个家伙
Garrett McNamara, I definitely told you about it in writing down what yeah watching watching what these big wave surfers do, not just Garrett, but all those guys, when I see those guys, when they're like, man, there's this storm coming to Portugal, to Nazareg, we gotta get there, we've got 48 hours, we need to get there, cause there's a fucking crazy storm, and I need to get on a surfboard and have a dude tow me in behind a ski-doo so I can get on the storm waves.
加勒特·麦克纳马拉制作的，我绝对在写作时跟你提过，是啊，看着这些大浪冲浪手在做什么，不仅仅是加勒特，还有所有那些家伙，当我看到那些家伙时，当他们说，天哪，有个风暴正朝葡萄牙纳扎雷袭来，我们得去那儿，我们只有48小时，我们需要去那儿，因为有个他妈的疯狂风暴，我需要踩上冲浪板，让一个家伙用滑雪板把我拖到风暴浪里去。
And I'm thinking like, I'm looking for the closest restaurant that's got a happy hour. I wanna make sure, what do they have on draft? I'm looking for the next Harry Potter movie. I'm like, crazy. But yeah, that's insane. So are you guys, is it fun? Have you guys been having a good time?
而我在想，我在找离得最近的有欢乐时光的餐馆。我想确保，他们有什么生啤？我在找下一部《哈利·波特》电影。我觉得，太疯狂了。但是，是的，这太疯狂了。所以你们两个，这好玩吗？你们过得开心吗？
Is it like, it's gotta be fascinating to learn all these stories. They sound incredible. It's so fascinating. Yeah, I mean, just talking to Ty Stokes, who was on the Jamaican founding member of the Jamaican bobsled team, the real story behind that team
这感觉，了解所有这些故事一定很迷人。听起来太不可思议了。太迷人了。是的，我的意思是，仅仅是跟牙买加雪橇队的创始成员之一泰·斯托克斯（Ty Stokes）交谈，那支队伍背后的真实故事
is so much more interesting than the movie. Cool Runnings? Yeah, Cool Runnings butchered it. Like the actual story. Wait, now you're telling me that the Disney movie Cool Runnings that was trying to capitalize on the Jamaican bobsled team, did it, was it true?
比电影有趣得多。冰上轻驰（Cool Runnings）？对，《冰上轻驰》把它给糟蹋了。就像真实的故事。等等，现在你在告诉我，那部试图利用牙买加雪橇队热度的迪士尼电影《冰上轻驰》，它，那是真的吗？
I'm sorry to take this away from you. Really? That's great. Cool story? Oh, it's an insane story. He got put on this team like a mere months before the Olympics started. They didn't have a bobsled, they didn't have a bobsled track.
很抱歉打破你的幻想。真的吗？那太棒了。好故事？哦，这是个疯狂的故事。他在奥运会开始前短短几个月就被塞进了这支队伍，他们没有雪橇，他们没有雪橇赛道。
They'd never been on ice? Yeah, they didn't have a place to train. They didn't even get to go down the, a bobsled down the, what do you call it? The hill or whatever? The track with a, like what, two or three weeks before the Olympics for the first time. Yeah, yeah How do they call you know this they they ended up training for money. They trained on daiquiris, but they would go How do they qualify anyway, you know what we're gonna listen to the podcast that yeah, we're gonna find we're gonna listen to it
他们从来没在冰上滑过？对，他们没有地方训练。他们甚至没有去过，坐雪橇下那个，你们叫它什么？山坡还是什么的？带着，比如，在奥运会前两三周第一次滑赛道。是啊，是啊。他们怎么会，你知道吗，他们为了钱训练。他们喝代基里酒训练，但他们会去……不管怎样，你知道吗，我们要去听那个播客，我们要去找，我们要去听。
Yeah, I can't wait. It's called Pretty Sure I Can Fly. It's Johnny Knoxville and Elna Baker together again. You guys make such a great pair. The show sounds so awesome. I truly can't wait to listen to it. It is available right now on whatever podcast platform you're currently listening to.
是的，我等不及了。它叫《我敢说我能飞》。这是强尼·诺克斯维尔和埃尔娜·贝克再次合作。你们俩真是绝配。这个节目听起来太棒了。我真的迫不及待想听了。它现在已经在你目前正在收听的任何播客平台上架了。
Yeah, thank you. Thank you so much, Johnny and Elna. All right, thank you. Thank you. Thanks, guys. Thanks a lot. we appreciate it. We're about to play a clip from Pretty Sure I Can Fly. Follow Pretty Sure I Can Fly on the Wondery app
好的，谢谢。非常感谢，强尼和埃尔娜。好的，谢谢。谢谢。谢谢大家。非常感谢。我们即将播放一段《我敢说我能飞》的剪辑。在 Wondery App 上关注《我敢说我能飞》
or wherever you get your podcasts. ["Pretty Sure I Can Fly"] Ladies and gentlemen, Travis Mastrana. Everybody in this house is now standing up and cheering on the 199. Go Travis! Can you tell me the story of the double backflip? Because that to me was also, I mean, I got chills in that moment in the movie, but I would love to hear you tell me the story.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。《我敢说我能飞》女士们先生们，特拉维斯·帕斯特拉纳（Travis Pastrana）。这屋里的每个人现在都起立为199号选手欢呼。上吧，特拉维斯！你能给我讲讲双后空翻的故事吗？因为对我来说，这也是，我的意思是，电影里那一刻我起鸡皮疙瘩了，但我很想听你给我讲讲那个故事。
There's very few times in your life where something that means so much to you means so much to a group around you. And even more rare that it means that much to the world. I still have people tell me almost once a week, I get someone that still remembers where they were at that moment. You know, my grandma and all her friends watch it. It's live on TV. My mom was crying because she had known that, you know, I'm about 75% into the foam pit,
你生命中很少有这样的时刻：对你意义重大的事情，对你周围的一群人也意义重大。而更罕见的是，它对全世界也具有如此重大的意义。现在几乎每星期都还有人对我说，总有人还记得他们在那一刻身在何处。你知道，我奶奶和她所有的朋友都在看。电视直播。我妈妈在哭，因为她知道，你知道的，我大概有75%的把握能落入海绵坑，
but if it comes around short, there's a really good chance of a broken neck or paralyzed or it was a really cool moment. Even up until you did it, it seemed like, was it really like, I don't know if I'm going to go through with it or not. And the reason, like we were just explaining, like you always say, I't know if I'm gonna go through with it or not and the reason like we were just explaining like You always say I'm in or I'm out the reason this was such a tough decision for me And I think the reason that got built up more Was because I was on the fence on this I have an opportunity to go out there and try a trick that I've been working
但如果转过头来差了一点，很有可能会脖子骨折或者瘫痪，那真是一个非常酷的时刻。甚至直到你做的那一刻，看起来好像，是不是真的像，我不知道我是不是要坚持到底。原因就像我们刚刚解释的那样，你总是说，我不知道我是不是要坚持到底，而原因就像我们刚刚解释的那样，你总是说，我行或者我不行，这个决定对我来说之所以如此艰难，而且我认为之所以被炒得那么热，是因为我在这件事上举棋不定。我有一个机会去尝试一个我已经练习了
For for three four years, but I'm sitting third so I'm like if I don't do a double backflip I still get a medalip, I still get a medal. I still get paid, which is gonna really help everything else that I've been putting into rally. And is my goal to be a freestyle motocross rider or is my goal to continue on in action sports and to have a career that's gonna expand hopefully longer? And it worked out in rally. And I said, you you know what I'm both
三四年的绝技，但我当时排在第三位，所以我想如果我不做双后空翻，我仍然能拿到奖牌，我仍然能拿奖牌。我仍然能拿到报酬，这对于我一直在投入拉力赛的所有其他事情将会有很大帮助。我的目标是成为一名自由式摩托车越野赛车手，还是我的目标是继续从事极限运动，并拥有一份希望能够更持久的职业？它在拉力赛中成功了。我说，你知道吗，我两个都要。
Said I'm gonna land this trick and went out there and decided like literally last second played rock-paper-scissors with my redneck friend Hubert Wait you you the the deciding factor was a rock-paper-scissors Right before I went up there Hubert we went rock-paper-scissors I gave thumbs up to basically Sal and the guys and they're like, alright They raised the ramp and no one has ever done this before At that time I had done it to a sand pile in a controlled environment. That was a big step up So if you came up short or didn't make it it sucked, but it was yeah It's like yeah, it was a hard surface that day, right? It was just blue groove.
我说我要落地这个绝技，然后走出去，决定就在字面意思上的最后一秒，和我的红neck朋友休伯特玩石头剪刀布。等等，你，决定性因素是一场石头剪刀布？就在我上去之前，休伯特，我们玩了石头剪刀布。我对萨尔（Sal）和伙计们竖起了大拇指，他们就像，好吧。他们升起了坡道，以前从来没有人这样做过。
It was pretty much worst case scenario for me. We took the ramp that was already existing and then raised it on two by fours. And like it looked like something we built in our backyard for like, you know, when we were five years old. And it's like, you know, my dad's out there like strapping the ramp down and trying to get it so it doesn't move because if the ramp falls over, then I'm definitely gonna deep trap.
那时我只在受控环境下的沙堆上做过。那是一个很大的跨度。所以如果你差了一点或者没成功，那就太糟了，但它就是，是的。那天那是硬质表面，对吧？那基本上就是“蓝色沟槽”（硬实平整的赛道）。那对我来说几乎是最糟糕的情况。我们用了现有的坡道，然后在上面用二乘四木方加高了。而且它看起来就像我们在后院自己搭的东西，就像，你知道的，我们五岁的时候搭的。而且就像，你知道的，我爸爸在那儿用带子把坡道绑起来，试图把它固定住，好让它不会动，因为如果坡道倒了，那我就绝对死定了。
And so you're up there and you're about to go. Yeah, it was one of the coolest experiences ever. Got up there and the guy that drops me in, he gave me a thumbs up. He said, it's on you, take your time. And I looked around and every single person was on their feet. Entire sold out, Staples Center, all of my heroes,
所以你站在上面，你正准备出发。是的，这是有史以来最酷的经历之一。站上去之后，那个把我放下去的家伙给我竖了个大拇指。他说，看你的了，慢慢来。我环顾四周，每一个人都站了起来。整个座满的斯台普斯中心（Staples Center），我所有的英雄，
you had Kevin Robinson, you had Chad Kegge, they were holding hands. I had Brian Deegan, all the militia was all down there looking. It was one of the coolest experiences and I remember inside my helmet smiling and when I dropped in everything kind of went to slow motion. Usually you get to slow motion if anyone's crashed a car
你有凯文·罗宾逊（Kevin Robinson），你有查德·卡吉（Chad Kage），他们手拉着手。我有布赖恩·迪根（Brian Deegan），所有的民兵队员都在下面看着。这是最酷的经历之一，我记得在头盔里微笑着，当我滑下去的时候，一切都变成了慢动作。通常情况下，如果有人撞了车，你会经历慢动作，
or been in a really bad, like where you think everything's going bad. I've never had slow motion where I took off and I can remember the smells, I can remember the sounds, I can remember everything was so vivid. And I came around on the first pull and I checked the landing and I remember thinking, as Trevor Jacobs said later, he's like, oh, you can't check.
或者陷入非常糟糕的境地，你会觉得一切都在变坏。我从来没有在起飞时经历过慢动作，我能记得气味，我能记得声音，我能记得一切都是那么生动。我在第一圈转过来时检查了着陆点，我记得当时想，正如特雷弗·雅各布斯（Trevor Jacobs）后来所说的那样，他就像，哦，你不能检查。
And I'm like, oh no, now I'm short. And I whip my head back and I see the lights. So when you practice this trick, you know, in the foam pit, you have, you know, you got the sky above you and in the ground. But on this day, you've got blinding lights where you can't see anything straight ahead of you and then below you is kind of dark. And I just remember kind of just smiling again. I'm like, well, I'm all in.
而我在想，哦不，现在我转短了。我把头猛地往回一甩，看到了灯光。所以当你练习这个绝技时，你知道，在海绵坑里，你有，你知道的，你头顶上有天空，脚下有地面。但在这一天，你有着刺眼的灯光，让你在正前方什么也看不清，然后你脚下有点黑。我只记得自己又笑了笑。我想，好吧，我全押上了。
I can't get out of this now. And I came around and like literally hit, couldn't have hit better. And I was just like, what the heck just happened? I dropped down and dropped the bike and I run up. And the first person there was just some drunk guy out of the stands that just overpowered the security and gave me a big hug up top. Like, I don't even know you, but yes, let's go. Oh, my word. Are you kidding me? How many times can you find the Holy Grail in one building?
我现在可退不出去了。我转过来，字面意思上落地了，不可能落得更好了。我当时就想，刚才到底发生了什么？我滑下去，把车扔下，然后跑了过去。第一个到那儿的人只是看台上的一个酒鬼，他突破了安保，在上面给了我一个大大的拥抱。就像，我甚至不认识你，但太棒了，我们上吧。哦，我的天哪。你在开玩笑吗？你怎么能在同一栋大楼里找到这么多次圣杯？
A double backflip from Travis Pastrana. So that was pretty cool. I was at home watching it live and it was like, I had tears going down my cheeks like the end of Old Yeller because it was such an amazing moment and so memorable. Yeah, I was blown away. Is that, you think that's the biggest moment of your career or?
来自特拉维斯·帕斯特拉纳的双后空翻。所以那真的很酷。我在家里看直播，当时眼泪顺着脸颊流下来，就像《老黄狗》（Old Yeller）的结局一样，因为那是一个如此神奇、如此难忘的时刻。是的，我惊呆了。那是，你认为那是你职业生涯中最伟大的时刻吗，还是？
Moment that the world felt what I felt. You can listen to Pretty Sure I Can Fly early and ad free by joining Wondery Plus. Join Wondery Plus in the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. If you like Smart List, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey.
那个让全世界感受到我的感受的时刻。你可以通过加入 Wondery Plus 提前且无广告地收听《我敢说我能飞》。在 Wondery App 或 Apple Podcasts 上加入 Wondery Plus。如果你喜欢 Smart List，现在就可以通过在 Wondery App 或 Apple Podcasts 上加入 Wondry Plus 来提前且无广告地收听。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上无广告收听。在你离开之前，请在 Wondery.com/survey 填写一份简短的调查问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。
Hey, listener, it's Jason Bateman. You know him for putting his body on the line in Jackass, but now Johnny Knoxville's bringing you the wildest stories from the bravest folks he knows on his new podcast, Pretty Sure I Can Fly. His new podcast in collaboration with us here at Smartless Media also features long time This American Life contributor, Elna Baker, as his co-host.
嘿，听众朋友们，我是杰森·贝特曼。你可能知道他在《蠢蛋搞怪秀》里奋不顾身，但现在，约翰尼·诺克斯维尔在他的新播客《我确信我会飞》中，为你带来他认识的最勇敢的人们最疯狂的故事。他的这个与我们Smartless传媒合作的新播客，还邀请了长期担任《This American Life》撰稿人的埃尔纳·贝克担任联合主持人。
Together they have incredible first-hand accounts from folks who surf hundred-foot waves, ride 600 mile per hour rocket sleds, and wrestle crocodiles for fun. On Pretty Sure I Can Fly, Johnny and Elna bring you personal stories from unsung heroes that are part comedy, part adrenaline, and all heart. These are the inspirational Hold My Beer stories that will make you want to grab the bull by the horns, literally and figuratively. Follow Pretty Sure I Can Fly on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts.
他们一起带来了许多精彩的第一手经历，讲述了那些冲浪百尺巨浪、乘坐时速600英里火箭雪橇以及为了好玩而与鳄鱼搏斗的人们的故事。在《我确信我会飞》中，约翰尼和埃尔纳为你带来无名英雄的个人故事，其中既有喜剧色彩，又有肾上腺素飙升的刺激，更充满了真挚的情感。这些都是鼓舞人心的“看我的”式故事，会让你想字面意义和比喻意义上都勇敢地迎难而上。在Wondry应用或你获取播客的任何地方关注《我确信我会飞》。
You can listen to Pretty Sure I Can Fly early and ad-free right now on Wondry+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你现在就可以在Wondry+上提前且无广告地收听《我确信我会飞》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。